two-year-old grandmother unfortunately
passed away God bless her soul
um
representative Daniel Bayou thank you
welcome to the labor committee
uh representative Granger is absent
today we replaced by representative
Tudor thank you welcome
and back for a second try uh filling in
for representative Mason
Arizona Board
welcome
if you would just pass that down to the
clerk so he has just their name so he
the first bill in front of us oh I'm
sorry we need to uh we if everyone would
um
please stand representative Broody would
opening the executive session
on House Bill 241.
relative to the opportunity of School
District employees representing
collective bargaining unit to meet the
public employee as part of collective
bargain negotiations
thank you Mr chairman I would move itl
motion on the floor is an expedient to
legislate
representative love seconds in motion
the motion has been made and seconded
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman
um we were brought forward an issue that
seems to be very specific
to one bargaining agreement one unit
maybe particular individuals involved
with that
and
it just seems to me that the process
that is already in place was not used
and it's intended to resolve these
issues
the understanding of of the way it's
supposed to work is when
uh the employees and the management do
not agree on on when
the times to meet how often to meet that
those things are negotiated and if
necessary a balance a compromise must be
struck
um
if that can't happen and that and and
when this bill was brought forward it
said it suggested that the RSA always
favors the employees if they demand to
meet during a certain time that does not
appear to be the position of the peorb
and
um in this case it was not taken to the
pelrb so to me if we saw that there was
really an issue with how the plrb ruled
and they they said well this we're
basing this ruling on this law and so
that's the way we have to go I would
consider looking at the law and how it
might be changed but it never even got
that far so I think this law is
premature at best and from what we heard
probably unnecessary
representative Sullivan
yet again I am in full agreement with
representative seaworth
um the
the peo pelrb has ruled on this issue
from time to time and when they do they
basically tell the parties to do exactly
what the parties did which was sometimes
you negotiate during the day sometimes
you negotiate outside of the school day
so essentially the the what happened in
that town was exactly what the pelrv
would have ordered if it had gone to the
perv so I agree that this bill is uh
unnecessary and I will support itl thank
you
thank you representative Sullivan
are there any other representative will
you speak representative
thank you Mr chairman this is a quick
question
um the
I can't read who was filling in for last
for uh representative Mason I can't read
the um one of the things I've heard in
this committee for a number of years is
um the legislature New Hampshire should
not mess with the bargaining
relationships between
um
bargaining units and
who are they bargaining with
um whatever municipality or just or
organization that has to go both ways
you can't have it when you want it and
you not have it when you don't want it
so being consistent I will vote um
with uh representative Sullivan and
representative representative love
I'll also be voting to itl this uh
having been part of a bargaining unit
and uh and sat and negotiated with the
you know with the employers
um I I I can't see why we should be
giving special rights to the Public
Employee sector with that the private
private sector doesn't have I had to go
after work and and sit down and it was
always like that I was involved in two
or three contract negotiations and uh
you know we
we had to go after work it was uh just
uh uh almost like a public service for
the for uh for our fellow employees to
go do it and uh like I said I'd be real
reluctant to uh to give the public
sector bargaining units um more uh
I don't see any other additional hands
the motion on the floor is inexped into
legislate on House Bill 241 it's been
moved in second we've had a discussion
would you please call the roll
thank you Mr chairman
um representative seaworth yes
I will vote Yes representative power
yes representative love
yes John Boyd yes representative poker
yes representative
colcum yes
represent Drago yes representative tutor
yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Rudy yes representative
Cahill yes representative D Silvestro
yes representative Susie yes rep
representative Bouchard yes
representative attitude yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative yes
and representative 91 yes
yeah and the chairman chairman vote yes
thank you is unanimous Mr chairman
is there any um objection to this bill
be putting on the consent agenda
seeing none
thank you it's an agenda
representative Bouchard you get your
everything done
did you hit it out of the park
well uh you I was able to miss out on
very well
I want to give the clerk a minute here
to catch up
um if you did not have an opportunity to
see
um
my email that went around yesterday or
the day before I don't remember
I'd like to get you all out of here by
11 30. so if you would like to go over
to the retail merchants not the retained
Merchants thank you representative kale
for looking at my uh
with every all the emails we all write a
day sometimes just just keep typing
thank you
next bill is for example
10 15. so Mom I'm back on schedule
House Bill 410 relative to Municipal
ranking list promotions
representative seaworth you're
recognized
Mr chairman I'll move Ito
the motion on the floor is an expedient
to legislate seconded by representative
Boyd
motion of the floor is a speed late has
been
made and seconded representative
seaworth
my uh argument here is similar to the
last one this seems to be a bill brought
forward for a particular bargaining unit
a particular municipality
um
and uh the issue that it seeks to
address I understand is nepotism which I
don't think
any of us is in favor of favoring
unfairly some employees over others on
the other hand this isn't
really a nepotism bill
um and certainly when we heard from
the the police Representatives that were
here when we heard from the municipal
Association
um it seems like a solution that is not
suited for every case
uh I'd like to think that
there are other ways to resolve an issue
that is particular to a
a specific city or town
um and for that reason I would not
support
representative Susie
thank you Mr chairman and I too agree
with representative seaworth
um I think this is a bill that really
belongs uh what
the Crux of the building belongs and
collective bargaining
and I'm sympathetic to some of the
people I've lived it I've as as I stated
before 29 years in a fire service I was
on the executive board for 17 years
negotiating contracts I've seen many
changes bye I don't believe that because
there's an issue
this specific issue should be brought to
the legislature I believe truly believe
that it still belongs in negotiations
and collective bargaining and there are
ways to change it
um
sometimes it takes it's a lot to change
it but if you stand in and you dig your
feet in there's definitely ways to
change it so again I agree with the
representative seaward thank you Mr
chairman
representative
thank you Mr chairman we also heard
during testimony that there could be uh
this could want to file with some local
ordinances that have that are protecting
um promotional lists and things like
that so we uh I also don't think a
representative proud
thank you Mr chairman I think we also
heard um piggybacking after off of
Representative avalani's comment that
that same enabling authorization to
address this issue via local ordinances
could be used if largely fix this
problem on a Town by town or
municipality by municipality basis and
so
um doing a Statewide solution a
one-size-fits all when there's already
existing enabling legislation to let it
be done by the municipal legislature I
don't think is appropriate
seeing no oh representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to add
that I I think it must be very difficult
for the people who feel they're passed
over and I don't think it's helpful for
recruiting and retaining the people who
are dedicated to do this work
if they if they had the impression that
there's something else in the works I
know that some of this is subjective but
I I don't think it's conducive to having
that team of people that we need doing
this important work I realize this isn't
the solution uh but I I would hope that
the people involved would find a way to
all right
seeing no further hands
motion on the floor is an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 410
and move secondly we've had a discussion
oh yes representative private yes
representative yes representative Boyd
yes representative
yes
representative
yes representative Drago yes go upstairs
tutor yes represent Sullivan yes
representative Rudy yes representative
Cahill yes representative Silvestro yeah
representative Susie yes representative
shot yes representative attitude yes
representative McKenzie yes
oh sorry yes
I'm representative yes
your name is Mr chairman
and the objection to this bill being on
the consent agenda
seeing none
we'll do that
we have to wait six minutes seven eight
minutes uh whether uh House Bill 561 so
foreign
House Bill 561 establishing a committee
to examine Workforce and school
accommodations for those with long-term
covert and
mecfs representative Prout
thank you Mr chairman I move an
expedient to legislative on this bill
emotions in expedient to legislate have
thank you
motion made a second representative
Prout you're recognized to address your
motion thank you Mr chairman
um
I still have a lot of questions about
this bill a lot of what we heard of what
people are having trouble with
especially in the workplace should
already be covered under existing
non-discrimination for Disabilities law
Americans Disabilities Act or its
analogs at various agencies and levels
of government Etc
um
and uh I don't fully understand how what
their experience is distinguished from
other medical issues
um and while I understand people are
having issues
and they really want someone to be able
to tell them why and what can be done
for them
um a legislative study committee is a
very bad way to do novel novel medical
research which I think what is what
really might be what they need
and for those reasons I recommend uh IPL
on this bill
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
oppose itl on this film
um chronic fatigue syndrome is a very
miserable thing to live with I suspect
that the least we can do is establish a
committee to examine how CFS and me
interacts with present disability
accommodation law as it pertains to the
long covet aspect of this we are three
years into the pandemic slash endemic in
fact February 16 2020 the world reached
1770 deaths a number which very sadly
shrinks in comparison to what it is
today
three years down the road we have
learned that some individuals have
contracted covet in the last three years
and have had the symptoms and illness
for longer than the normal two weeks I
know I hated how I felt when I had it
for two weeks I couldn't imagine a month
or a year
and I feel enough time has passed where
we can acquire new data on individuals
with this unfortunate disease
as has been said many times in this
committee we have to learn to live with
covid and this is what learning to live
with it would look like but we need to
do that learning first
um I would be very interested to see how
long covid interacts with the current
workplace accommodation law that was
referenced as a consequence of that I'd
like to see the committee established
and I'm going to vote against the itl
representative Rudy thank you Mr
chairman
um this is a study committee and I
always look at study committees like
well if there's no problems they'll find
out or if there is a problem
let's try to get it fixed
covet hit us
we got blindsided by it and it set the
world upside down for a few years
they came out with a vaccine lightning
fast
we don't know what side effects are
going to come down the road we don't
know what the next step or the next
phase of covet's going to be I think the
cut this committee off and make it go
away is we're sure changing ourselves if
we do have a committee at least it's in
place to recognize a problem if one
comes up
thank you
representative McKenzie
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm going to vote against the itl
you know these are front line workers
these are people who uh during the
toughest of times uh they probably had
more exposure than many people uh in
this room
um
so I I think that it's an interesting
issue I'm not sure it's necessarily the
best issue to be in front of the house
labor committee and maybe there should
be another committee that looks at this
um but but I also and I you know I
acknowledge that there are Provisions in
the federal law the Americans with
Disability Act and all those kinds of
things and I don't know where those are
in terms of this but
I think that it is an emerging issue
relative to long-term impact that covet
has if it is affecting the workforce uh
I think it's worth a look at but again
I'm not sure this is the best committee
to take that up
um but I I would uh support the if the
only thing we have in front of us is the
opportunity to establish a committee
then I would support that idea and go in
experience allegedly vote against that
I'm just going to see where thank you Mr
chairman I I find some agreement with
the last two speakers
um
and yet I'm
going to vote for the itl I think in
some ways
this issue as was mentioned is a lot
bigger than a labor issue it's a lot
bigger than a New Hampshire issue it's a
national and an international issue it
involves medical science
and well I certainly appreciate
the suffering that the people who were
before us went through
um
a study committee isn't always the best
First Option when we don't know what
we're looking at certainly this year the
speaker has asked the house to look at
the numerous study committees that we've
established and try to
um
reduce that a little bit where where
appropriate it can be very difficult
finding the people who want to spend the
time on these additional committees to
study things
and so I'm cautious about authorizing a
committee where the scope of what's
being sought isn't clear
at the same time uh
my fellow representative brought up that
maybe we're looking too narrow with this
I
had an interesting experience I was into
the doctor with my kids one of the
issues is my son has no sense of smell
he never has and we went to the doctor
to discuss this and he said well one of
the first things I bring up is that it
may be related to a virus and I used to
say that nobody believed me now everyone
knows and but my point is that the long
coveted symptoms are not restricted to
Long covet there are a lot of viruses
that have long-term effects they're very
poorly understood
so are we focusing here on kind of the
issues due of the day and ignoring
as as my friend said uh vaccine and
negative impact reactions to the
vaccines or people that have developed
infections from masks or viruses that
are just not covered but still cause
these long-term employment issues so
again my point is that we've we've got a
very nebulous question a big question
and it it seems well beyond the labor
committee to deal with it so I'm
uncomfortable setting up this committee
thank you
I've heard people say that the reason
why we should not do a study committee
is because there are a lot of unknowns
things that we don't uh understand yet
about long coveted and I would suggest
that that's exactly why you do a study
committee to uncover the answers to the
unknowns so I'll be posing Ito in
supporting the study committee to try to
come up with some answers for these
folks and also try to help
figure out exactly what accommodations
are appropriate and possible for people
who are experiencing these uh illnesses
more of a question if I may
um
the study of the covid is is may or may
not be as important as people say but I
question whether or not why it didn't go
to a Health and Human Services committee
and came to a labor committee because it
has really nothing to do with labor and
everything to do with general population
health
and
I think this is the wrong committee for
doing something like that
myself
thank you representative Broody thank
you Mr chairman maybe that if we form
this committee people from Health and
Human Services should be on this
committee
if they know more about it than we do
there's an advantage it's gonna say I
can answer that question
um during the pandemic uh one of my
favorite things to say
um when it came to my opinion on uh
covert prevention procedure was I am not
a doctor
um and this would be a committee to
examine Workforce accommodations
um the folks over in the Health and
Human Services committee are not
familiar with this aspect of the law and
I don't think this can just be a hot
potato between those two committees
because eventually it turns into a game
of chicken and nobody takes it
um I think it's more appropriate for her
to start here and as the previous member
just said
um I don't believe that study committees
are restricted to the members of One
committee I'm willing to be wrong about
that
um but I don't think
it would be required for it to be
entirely members of this committee I can
absolutely see members of the Health and
Human Services committee that may want
thank you Mr chairman and we do have
several doctors in the house so
maybe they would have a better look at
things than
origin of love
yeah I'll be voting for The itl and the
reason being uh you know a little bit of
knowledge is dangerous and uh you know
to have a labor committee where we have
no uh no viral Specialists and and what
have you you know people that are really
knowledgeable about this this subject uh
you know we won't have them on this
committee and uh we could do more damage
my concern here and why I will support
the itl is we have I've just listened
it's been fascinating
this is supposed to do one thing
the bill is supposed to look at
accommodations
for school and Workforce for people with
long-term covered
and such
yet half the discussion here has been
Medical
has not had to do with that I firmly
believe there are long-term covered
issues No Doubt
how it affects everyone's different
abilities how it's affected everyone
and family members who have been
affected in totally different ways
so no doubt then we get into the whole
thing about well is something in the
vaccines causing things that's not on
the table here that's not what this is
about and half of the discussion has
been about that
the discussion here in the in the bill
is about accommodations for workforces
I am not aware and I I
I had a time on a plane and I read
anything I could find about Googling
this
and I haven't seen anything I I talked
to the labor department have there been
any issues with someone being released
not being given the accommodations
um and I had no I didn't have anyone to
think of to call
um for the school
but we do have an issue
with long term
no doubt
but that's not what this study committee
is yet that is when three quarters of
the discussion
that's my concern we're not going to
talk about this and we don't have
anything to talk about it about because
we don't know that it has been a problem
and that it's not covered under current
law
now I'm all in favor of people studying
things I think this best thing that we
as Representatives is dig into some of
these things and I'm all in favor and
I've supported a lot of things how many
times last year
um representative Sullivan did I support
against the speaker support something
which we're going to be speaking of the
um so I'm all in favor of doing it but
this in my opinion is not doing what it
is just the mere fact of what the
discussion has been on the on the
executive session so
um
that's
that's what I'm that's what is it I'm
sticking to it representative Cahill uh
thank you Mr chair
um in addition to covid you know chronic
fatigue syndrome is something else me
I'm not going to try to pronounce what
that stands for but these are a sort of
recognized conditions that we've had you
know in the world before covet and I
well I I don't know whether or not a
person with any of these conditions is
able to get the accommodations they need
I think that was this that's what why
we're here what why the subject was
brought to us and uh if we could find
out some in some way whether or not that
was a problem whether the study
committee is the way to do that I'm not
sure but I'd like to support those
people who are having these conditions
and finding it difficult to work
thank you and I was warned that a little
knowledge is a dangerous thing but I'm
gonna charge ahead anyway I I know a
little about
how these issues connect and I'll just
share that I I think the connection
between long covid myalgia and chronic
fatigue syndrome is these are medical
issues that are widely reported I I know
people that have suffered from them but
medical science cannot make connections
between the causes and effects in the
way that
most diseases and most disabilities are
made and so the question was what's the
threat here and I would suggest that
that's the threat that it's a disconnect
between what people
feel what science says about it and
maybe the way the workplace treats
differently a known disability from a
representative proud
thank you Mr chairman
so
back to the the the the root of the
topic of this bill it's about workplace
accommodations and knowing things about
that it's those are supposed to be the
only reason those should be denied is if
they cross the boundary into the the
request is unreasonable
uh extreme for the business to be con to
be asked to do
and at that point it's supposed to
bridge over into is the person disabled
should they go on permanent disability
is at least how I view the world or how
I view how all those laws are supposed
to interact and so if there's an issue
there's probably an issue of
there's a gap in between those two where
a person is asking for accommodations
that are going so far as to be
considered unreasonable yet they're not
able to get their permanent disability
and be not expected to work
that would be the Gap that we would I
would see that would need to be studied
but that's not the topic of the study
committee
all right thank you everyone
um we have a motion on the floor and
experience to legislate
it's been a second and there's been
discussion Mr clerk we've uh please call
the roll I got to start saying this if
you're in favor of the motion you vote
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
seaworth yes
yes representative yes representative
representative boy yes
representative poker yes representative
colcum yes representative Draco yes
president tutor yes
representative Rudy no representative
Cahill no representative D Silvestro yes
representative Susie
representative Bouchard no
representative attitude
representative McKenzie no
representative Nettie Wong no and
representative
no
motion passes 12
it is not 11 o'clock but I would like to
um
the committee to bear with me for a
in and we're not an executive session
this is just me trying to make a point
to the committee of what I would like to
do
I grew up in a town
Amherst 1700 people 1970s it wasn't for
the volunteer firefighters a lot of bad
things would have happened
so I understand the need
I'm also wrestling with it telling
forcing businesses to do certain things
which I think the bill has gone a little
too far
my intent here was to retain the bill
and I
um thought about it over the last couple
uh last week or so and we have done very
well in getting our agenda done here and
we have time
I have we have another three weeks or
four weeks before all of the bills have
to be out of here
the remaining three bills we have on the
table
one I've gotten to sponsor to agree to a
retain and the other two we have study
committees after we're done today
so it is is my request the board of the
committee here that if I open the
executive session on House Bill 182 FN
and then close it and then see if I can
work out something with the sponsors
that is a little more
um
a little happier what would go on and
that was that would be my request
representative
thank you Mr chairman um I can't speak
for other members of the committee but I
would want to say that I would
um strongly oppose
um putting this off the problem that I
see and maybe if somebody wants to
provide some specifics
um that I could entertain them these are
the identical protections that exist for
members of the National Guard and the
Armory Marine Navy Air Force and Coast
Guard Reserves
I don't see what splitting the
difference here is
they are protections that would ensure
that they don't get fired for
having to respond to calls
I like I said I'm willing to listen to
specifics but I think this is a valuable
bill you know as we talked about in the
public hearing you know the example was
given of the former member of the
committee who is an airplane pilot it's
like well you know what happens if you
call out of work well it's not really
great well what happens if that person
you know doesn't call out of work so
this doesn't just apply to fall uh
volunteer firefighters it applies to EMS
that is lives on the line uh and I hate
to rise to that level of hyperbole but
it's a fact
um
I really just don't understand what
compromise could possibly exist here
where everybody's going to be happy if
they're going to be protections then the
employer is not going to be thrilled 100
of the time however as I said they are
the identical protections that we
already have for reservists the only
complaint that I would have about this
bill is that it doesn't extend to you
know other facets of the emergency
response system
um but that doesn't sound like the
direction that the compromise would be
intended to go in so I can just say that
I would oppose putting this off because
I don't see a resolution
the difference would be this walks out
of here today A 10 10 no recommendation
or it waits three weeks
and I bring something forth
that could possibly be unanimous
thank you if I may bring this up here I
did
um spend some time talking with police
fire chiefs and a Gentleman who I worked
with who is a volunteer firefighter and
has been for 30 years to get their
opinions on this and the gentleman I
worked with for for 25 years said that
over his 30-year career as a volunteer
firefighter he's only missed work five
to six times due to the need to respond
to fire he did say though that there are
a handful of people who do abuse the
privilege of going to fill up the the
fire truck and take any opportunity they
can to volunteer for other aspects that
really are not required for them to miss
their other employment
um so I do think that there may be some
slight abuse to this and in speaking
with a couple of local Fire Chiefs
um you know their opinion on this is if
they aren't responding to a fire or
emergency actual emergency call then
they should not be skipping work to
address other issues within the
firehouse but they also said this is
truly not a volunteer that they are paid
for their services when they're
responding
representative Drago again this is in
informal I appreciate it
um the conversation I
so to try to keep it um
on the subject that I would like to open
it close it and then try to work on it
with a sponsor some more that is the
only thing I'm asking go ahead represent
dragon
the only thing I was thinking is you
were asking about the difference between
the National Guard and possibly a first
responder I think a National Guard
for the most part unless it's a flooding
situation maybe they get called up but
for the most part they know when they're
going to be deployed and gives a
business a chance to
find a substitute for the duration that
they're gone whereas if somebody takes
an emergency call tomorrow that business
may not necessarily
um have the manpower to fill in for the
job that's supposed to be done that day
that's the only difference I can think
of but you are asking and that's what
representative pathogen and then
representative McKenzie
and then love so just want to touch on
that
um I am a proud veteran of the United
States Marine Corps Reserve
um
the National Guard in New Hampshire has
a little bit more of a reliable schedule
but I cannot count the number of times
where uh squad leader texted on Tuesday
night by the way you got to be here
Thursday morning when we were not
intending to have drill until Saturday
or Sunday
um it's not always that predictable
um when you're 80 or full-time service
in the summer gets scheduled it's not
always as ahead of the clock as possible
um that's that's on that point
um to respond to the chairman like I
said I would be very interested to see
some more specifics
um as I told my ranking member a couple
minutes ago
um
a wise person once said to me that the
longer you give something to go wrong
the more likely it is that it will
um and I believe in this bill very
strongly so
Mackenzie thank you Mr chairman
um
so what's what's being asked of us
by you as a chair is that you would like
some time
to be able to um to look at some uh some
aspects of this bill potentially come
back
um the situation we'll be in at that
point is it could be potentially an
amendment offered we could reject the
amendment and vote on the actual bill
was presented uh so we'll be in the same
basically you could be back in the same
position uh I I would um you know I
would support the the concept of us of
allowing uh you and and people that
you're working with uh more time to be
able to do this we have some time to do
this uh I would say uh you know in
response to my colleague uh you know the
EMS system and the fire system uh and
the the role that volunteers playing
that it's an important role in New
Hampshire
um you know as a as a person who has
spent 27 years in in Manchester fire I
would much rather see full-time
firefighters but the reality is to many
cities and towns that's not possible so
this is a this is a vehicle uh you know
as a professional firefighters we worked
hard to uh to make sure that the
volunteers live up to certain standards
uh that they go there many of them are
going to school on the side and learning
and getting certified uh so it's a much
different uh business today for
volunteer firefighters but I would
support the concept of you taking a bit
more time if you need it and then come
back and we'll take a look at what the
uh what your work is and what you
thank you Mr chair uh I'd certainly be
uh in favor of your proposal
um the the bills to me needs work
um you know and representative Edgerton
talked about uh you know a two-day
notice uh these people uh don't have
20-minute notices and uh for a small
business to somebody that for a business
with you know two three four five
employees uh that that could be have a
devastating effect
um you know we I think it needs to be
amended to to have a at least a you know
a minimum employee
um
um language in there uh you know I could
see it being good for a a company with
25 employees but not somebody with five
and uh you know uh I'd be in favor of
that but uh you know as it sits right
now I'd have to you know be voting for a
for an itl on it
representative colquin
so my question that I would like to
learn a little bit more about is
when you are deployed or sent out a
National Guard or any other Reserve do
you have the ability to decline that
um where I would say at the volunteer
firefighter or EMS they do have the
ability to decline it they may choose
not to and rightfully so but I don't
believe it it's a requirement that they
are you are you asking a representative
attitude
okay I'm sorry
I'm
um
representative Sullivan followed by uh
Brody
thank you
um
first of all having served as chair of
the committee
um I understand that you as chair are
not asking us but you get to schedule
things so I I know you're not a
heavy-handed uh chair but basically you
get to schedule and if you've decided to
put this off it's going to be put off I
get that and that's that's fine
um
I would simply suggest that we proceed
with caution because I wouldn't want the
pendulum to swing so far that we end up
with another 10 10 vote for different
reasons
um so that
let's be careful as we go forward
because if you amend too far people will
withdraw their support for other reasons
um one other point I believe that
most folks self-select
with regard to volunteering or not
volunteering for these roles if you know
you've got a job that won't tolerate
being a wave on short notice you don't
volunteer I I would have liked to but on
the volunteer fire department in
Grantham but I had a job that would not
have tolerated it I was
on the road all the time I wouldn't have
been available I wouldn't have been able
to get out for a fire so it didn't fit
my life so I uh I never volunteered and
I think a lot of that happens people
know that my job is one where I can step
away without the sky falling
so I I don't think it's as big a problem
as we make it out to be
but I also hear what folks are saying
about there being a lack of volunteers I
hear that there's a lack of full-timers
so essentially anything we can do to
bolster the core of volunteers for these
roles I think we should do but
let's pause let's try to make it better
and let's be careful while we do it
thank you
representative Rudy thank you Mr
chairman
um half of the reasons why I spoke on
the last bill is the same reasons for
this one
um I'm always ready to look at something
and see if we can't make it better
um one thing about especially a small
town if
if I have a job that takes up a lot of
time and I don't think I can serve I
won't serve however
getting any kind of help if this if your
house is on fire
and there's a couple of people who might
be available might be able to help out
you'd appreciate them if they were there
and if they just take themselves out of
the game ahead of time
they're not going to be available so I
think anything we can come up with is
probably better than what we have now
and I'm willing to take a look and see
if you can come up with something
instead of drawing a Line in the Sand
today thank you thank you representative
Drago
I just want to share my own personal
thought on this maybe that's something
everybody can think about and figure out
a way to make it work I do agree about
having a minimum amount of employees
because taking away
one employee went to two employee
business is a lot different than taking
away an employee from say a Walmart who
can Shuffle employee around for a few
hours
during the testimony one of the big
things they said well one of the selling
points was that we didn't have to pay
him which I don't think most businesses
would worry about that some probably
would but
uh the big thing was that they might
show up a few hours late
uh I own a landscape business and part
of that snow removal and my concern
would be
if it's snowing in the morning which is
probably when a lot of people might get
called in for an emergency
that plow route possibly is not being
covered if Mrs Smith walks out of her
condo and slips
because that parking lot wasn't cleared
who's responsible for that it's probably
going to be me as a business owner
I can't do anything about replacing the
employee under this bill
but yet I can't perform my job and now
I'm liable so I don't know how we go
about fixing that but that's going to be
a problem for a lot of different
employers across the state of if if this
thank you origin of avaloni thank you Mr
chairman
um as a business owner if the person
leaves during the day to handle a call
and gets injured
um
does the employee is the employer on the
hook for workman's compensation or is
the fire department on hook for
compensation and if they're injured how
do we handle that going forward if
they're unable to perform their duties
at work do we have to hold the job Farm
because they're on workman's
compensation under another
um employer at the time or is the
their regular full-time employer have to
hold their job because they want to if
I don't I don't want to get into
answering for the Department of Labor I
do know the answers to some of those but
uh yes yes and no
um
just so you guys understand what I'm
looking at okay
I think the time of effect of 60 days
after passage I just think it needs a
little more time maybe 120 days
something like that not a lot just will
be the notification time for employers
second thing line five no employer shall
discharge 100 okay with that
not just charging
or take any other disciplinary actions
they'd like to work something where if
someone's abusing the situation they can
be put on notice by the employer
not a lot of things here that I'm
looking for a little bit of
um ability for the employer to say hey
look you know it it it just been a lot
of different things here you can't you
know it's causing a problem them to be
able to at least have some kind of a say
but they can't be discharged for showing
up to a fire or an emergency call
so those are some of the small changes I
would like to make
um to the bill we're not talking about a
wholesale things representative Sullivan
you know I'm not trying to put a poison
pill in here okay I don't have the votes
to get you what you want
I don't feel good
as an individual
arguing against this bill on the house
floor
what good is it if I already know that
there's going to be some roadblocks if I
if it does pass
by just a couple votes in the house and
it goes to Senate and is killed
so if I can put something together that
I can get a number of Republicans on
this committee to go with and I can at
on the house floor
adequately speak
on something consistent with what we
normally do here in the labor committee
is to let the employers have a say when
needed then the chance of me walking
over to the Senate and testifying that
I'm in favor of this and getting this
bill passed because what good is it we
pass it here and it's not good enough to
get passed over there and I'm trying to
think
a little bit further and and my
conscience will not conscience will not
killing this bill
knowing all these small towns
any other
representative kale
thank you Mr chair and I certainly
appreciate your laying your cards on the
table
and I I would support extending it
giving it more time to work that and
maybe a few other things out I was
interested in the idea of a minimum
number of employees
maybe 15 that's the number that's been
used Elsewhere for the Department of
Labor
and so that might help get a couple more
people on board
and also I think the language it doesn't
talk a bit about it being emergency not
filling up the
the going to go I see people driving the
fire truck going to the go to the
supermarket I don't think that applies
here that's the professionals that do
thank you Mr chairman and I think you
know
continuing on the the other odd
situations that you can see coming up
here is
um you know I'm not sure if
canceling the balance of the shift would
be considered the disciplinary action
which I could absolutely see happening
in some cases whereas if you don't show
up at the start of the day and you're
supposed to you know join a crew and go
go jointly on a truck somewhere if you
show up late you miss the truck
what's the employer supposed to do
in that scenario and so um I don't know
whether showing you know saying the
employer saying no you can't show up
halfway through the shift and expect us
to make it work whether that would be
considered other disciplinary action
yeah I'm not going to try to micromanage
anything I'm just going to make it so
and then people can discuss you know we
do have a labor department to adjudicate
some of these things I'm trying to make
it just allowable
um
so it's not so hard and fast but I'm not
going to keep going I got two things
that we gotta represent Bouchard antigen
as I'm listening to the to the
discussion uh I I would hope that you
keep in mind that this is a cost
of having a volunteer fire department
I mean if you choose to have a volunteer
fire department
uh
and you're going to have this problem
so I think the
businesses should take that into
that's about that
great I'm just about agent
thank you Mr chairman
um I feel a little better having heard
specifics from you
um I can condone
um
taking a look at disciplinary action
line I
it's a little weird for me as far as
what counts as disciplinary action
um I can condone
um extending the days
um
I don't know I'm just I I wish we had
squared this away before today
um because I I like I said I like this
bill a lot I think it serves a valid
purpose I think it's fair
um for the salt of the earth individuals
who serve our communities as volunteer
firefighters
um
I'm annoyed about waiting but I get
annoyed in this building a lot so
um
I'll I will be grudgingly accept a delay
on the promise that the next time
um we exec that we have a plan to exec
this
I will
give you my word that the next time we
exactly we'll be executing this and it
will be something that I
whether my committee fellow Republicans
agree or not will be something that I'm
so that being said thank you for the
spirited and always spirited and polite
discussion that we have here I'm going
to open the executive session on House
and I would I'm going to then
um
recess
to be brought up at the future
our future and last executive session
represent Babylon I see your
just a quick question how does that how
do we
how do I uh we're going to have to ask
our I think you don't ever do anything
representative Broody you have
no
no it's just been open and and and and
recessed so no action was taken
thank you
um
got a couple minutes here I'm gonna
step out anyone like to take a water
break
uh
it will be executive session hearing on
House Bill 150 all representative
avaloni for a motion uh thank you Mr
chairman I move itl
motion on the floor is itl seconded by
representative love representative uh my
body
recognize speak thank you Mr chairman um
I think this has been uh brought up in
the past we went to five then we went
back to ten
um and I I think this is just history
repeating itself thank you
I'm sorry I didn't hear your last
sentence
it's history repeating itself oh thank
you representative Mackenzie followed by
so I'm sorry if you wouldn't mind
representative Sullivan followed by
Mackenzie
thank you
um
I think we heard testimony that the uh
number 10
um
number of people for a bargain unit was
arbitrary at the time it was put into
the law
um and I would acknowledge that five is
somewhat arbitrary as well however
um having um the number at five will
open the door to collective bargaining
for a greater number of public sector
employees and I think that's a good
thing so let's make uh collective
bargaining available to more more folks
having done this work I experienced um
going to a uh we're getting a call from
a group of employees who wanted to
organize and always having to tell them
the first thing you've got to do is
count to ten if you can't come up with
10 bodies you can't organize and I think
it would be a good thing if we could
replace that statement with all you've
got to do is count to five and I think
that'll be more readily accomplished and
more folks will have the opportunity to
have a say about their
terms of employment through collective
bargaining thank you
McKenzie thank you Miss chairman uh
I'm old enough to have been in the room
when when this law was actually passed
and I can attest to the fact that this
was no magic number 10 was just it was
just a number that was picked out of the
sky it was introduced by the gentleman
that was representing the university
system at the time
I had forgot that it had gone down to
five
and I'm not sure why I went back up to
10 but let me let's say in the federal
environment it's two
uh two people can be organized and in
fact I had a unit in my office that had
two people in it and they were
legitimate back in the unit recognizing
the National Labor Relations Act uh the
problem with the problem with keeping
the number high is um is it it
disenfranchises people and takes them
out of takes them away from that
opportunity that they would have to be
able to sit down with their employer and
negotiate a collective bargaining
agreement
and if the law right now encourages
people to bargain and the law says that
this is in the best interest of of uh
employees and Employers in the state of
New Hampshire if that is the opening uh
statement and it is within 273 uh then
there is no rationale for trying to keep
people out of that system
uh which is what this does
now there are other ways that you can
become a bargaining unit in the state
and here's a problem
if you're a firefighter and some town
you want to be with the firefighters you
don't necessarily want to be and not
disrespectful to the highway uh people
or others but you can organize units
which are a collection of of people from
different sectors as long as they have
what's known as a community of interest
and that happens and they're bargaining
units and I think that we heard some
testimony about that but if you're
working in the highway department you're
working on the police department you
want to be in a unit that that
recognizes your specific needs uh that
you might have firefighters needs and
and collective bargaining environment is
very different from a highway worker
and I think also uh in terms of
firefighters is that there is a whole
National Organization that they are not
able to participate in because they
can't get in a bargain units recognized
by the national firefighters so if in
fact the law is encourages people to
organize if it's uh if if you if you
look at the opening statement it says to
promote harmonious relations uh among
employees then the idea that we are
taking people out using this arbitrary
number uh is unfair uh it's unjust and
it uh it puts people in a position where
they may not have the opportunity to buy
them collectively and to have the chance
to be part of the of uh you know of a
unit that uh is able to sit down and and
again I have no idea why this number
came it was an arbitrary number it's
been in there it's not no reason has to
be locked in stone and it's contrary to
with the National Labor Relations law
says so Mr chairman I I think we should
you know bring the number down we should
bring it open it up so that people have
the opportunity thank you
thank you representative
um see worth thank you Mr chairman I've
heard uh a couple of my colleagues talk
about Public Employee organizing and
it's kind of representing representing
it as an unmitigated good
and I certainly can see the benefits of
uh
unionization in some cases I also
recognize that there's a cost to it and
I hope
uh that that also isn't a controversial
statement
um and I am also have been here long
enough that I remember the last time a
change in this bill
was made and part of that had to do with
the costs on very small organizations
and how that might impact the taxpayer
which if there are costs that's that's
where the burden falls in the previous
Bill we just talked about how maybe if
an organization is small enough
something that's a good idea for for a
larger group might not work for very
small groups and
I just want to recognize that that there
are benefits and there are also costs
representative love followed by Cahill
thank you Mr chairman I'm uh I'm glad
that representative seaworth brought up
the the employer the taxpayer uh it
seems an awful lot of times when we're
talking about public uh collective
bargaining we we forget all about them
um you know many contracts uh breed
confusion
you know if you if you've got a a town
yard with with six different contracts
in it and the guys are going one way and
another and
um you know everybody's got different uh
job responsibilities uh what a mess it
can make okay uh the the one thing that
uh that bothers me about this bill is um
you know there's some language in here
that's borderline controvers uh not
controversial uh uh conflicting that's
the word I'm looking for uh on line 13.
well the purpose of this section
probationary employees shall be counted
to satisfy the employee minimum number
number requirement then they can't vote
okay uh have a one way or the other
representative love um that's already
law
I think the only thing here we're
no disagreement what you're saying but
it's not germane to what we're voting on
here today I mean you're free to speak
on it but I just
thank you
anything else I didn't want to cut you
representative Cahill thank you Mr
chairman and I I just wanted you know
thinking about my colleague uh see where
his comments I wonder if another
possible downside would be that people
would leave small or would not apply to
smaller uh business opportunities
sectors because they wanted to be in the
union they saw the value in that and if
I if I if I can't do it if five I have
we're struggling to hire people and I
don't know if we should put limits on
anyone else want to speak first or first
time before I have someone speak a
second time
Mr chairman I uh I know it's not a
debate but I did want to just uh point
of water here uh you know my experience
with collective bargaining uh and a
contract
uh
contrary to I think what might have been
said is that it it sets the rules pretty
clearly
um if you talk about confusion in the
workforce I think it's a it's a
Workforce where it is not clearly
defined that there are discretionary
things which occur in workplaces that
Union environments don't allow you to do
that uh and I think the idea of having a
a collected buying agreement that
clearly states the rules that everybody
understands that everybody has agreed to
uh and that it is right out the front
for everybody to see including the
citizens I think that that's a
beneficial to the town uh to the
employees and to the employers within
the city within its cities and towns and
I guess I'm a little taken back by the
idea that that collective bargaining
makes it more expensive uh that somehow
that drives up costs which I think I'm
hearing uh in this discussion
I think that collective bargaining helps
to level the playing field
um it recognizes uh when you go to
mediation and other things like that it
recognizes the environment in which you
work uh it says uh especially in
mediation uh you know the firefighters
are in this town or that time of this
town you want some leveling of that so
and I think collective bargaining helps
you to do that because it recognizes the
environment in which you in which you
work and it gives you a target for
cities and towns to to go forth but that
said in the end it really is an
agreement between the local town the
board of Selectmen or whoever is the
board of aldermen and the employees and
uh negotiations can be tough and people
in this room have been part of it
um but it is uh it is a system that
works it has worked for many many years
there are thousands of employees in the
state of New Hampshire who work on the
collective buying agreements and is a
system that has managed uh to I think
Advance the interests of of the cities
and towns and the employees in the state
I I will say representative McKenzie you
always do a fantastic job supporting
members of uh unions
I have no problem with people joining
units I think it's fantastic go ahead I
think it's a great thing for this
country it's been a great thing for most
of our mission municipalities you have
100 firefighters and 150 police officers
can you imagine what it would be like if
you had to deal with a um uh salary
adjustments for each ones individually
like I have to do with my employees it
would be
you'd have one two people full time
just just doing that and so
I have no problem with Collective
barging I have no problem with people
getting involved I think it saves the
taxpayers money by having one group
organization to deal with one set of
rules as you said all those things you
so eloquently stated that are so
positive for that mechanism
this comes down to how many people pure
and simple not all the other stuff that
that why unions are good or or what have
you it comes down to how many people to
provide this we are not excluding people
from joining a union or creating a union
there are mechanisms in place for under
10 to people to join together it was
stated very clearly in one of the in in
the testimony that individuals could get
grouped together through another
mechanism uh it may not be perfect but
there are there is a certain cost to
having 20 bargaining units
in the municipality versus 10.
right it's twice as much of the time and
effort cost to negotiate them uh I think
there's it's reasonable
um that um
uh I don't think it's reasonable to have
units of two I think that you could have
just a tremendous amount I understand
that's a federal law uh and that's
that's fine uh this has nothing to do
with not wanting people to join unions
and be together and go collective
bargaining and you get better working
conditions and leveling the playing
field and getting better safety and all
the good things that come along with it
it's a simple associate of cost and how
many num units uh they're going to have
yeah nothing precludes any one group of
one or two
from joining a union they can join one
of the other
representative Rudy thank you Mr
chairman
um
we've been hearing about cost and for
the record I was a member of a
two-person shop and we were in a union
but one thing
a two-person or three-person facility
would would do
it would make the form and or whoever
listened to what's going on
many times the people actually doing the
work knows best they know what kind of
equipment to buy they know how to use
them and just because you're a worker
doesn't mean you don't have good ideas
this would force management into at
least listening
instead of just throwing out a mandate
and that this is just the way it's going
to be but if you're represented at least
you can get your point across on how
something could be good how something
can save money and maybe even save
all right thank you very much
um they're seeing no other hands
emotional floor is on Hospital 150 is
expecting to legislate it's been moved
second in discussion which if you were
in favor of the itl you'll vote Yes if
you were against your vote no Mr Clerk
thank you Mr chairman
representsy work yes I'll vote Yes
representative private yes
representative love yes representative
Boyd yes representative bowgert yes
representative colcum yes representative
Drago yes representative Tudor yes thank
representative Rudy no
representative Cahill no representative
Silvestro
no representative Bouchard no
representative attitude no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz excuse me
representative Nettie Wong
no Representative no thank you
uh chairman she asks thank you Mr
chairman
the um
uh motion pales is open tour a few uh
additional
motion
uh ought to pass by uh representative
attitude seconded by representative
Sullivan representative era of the floor
uh thank you Mr chairman I support the
and jumps on
I've had my say you know why I support
Auto pass so I'm ready to vote
any other comments sitting down the
motion on the floor is ought to pass
it's been moved and seconded if you're
in favor of the motion you'll vote Yes
if you're against the motion you vote no
Mr Clerk
yes
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
seaworth
no
representative private no representative
love no representative toyed no
representative Boger
no Representative colcom no
representative Draco no representative
Tudor no representative Sullivan yes
representative Rudy yes representative
Cahill yes representative Silvestro yes
representative yes representative
Bouchard yes representative attitude yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative 91 yes representative yes
and the chair
10 10 motion you know the motion Mr
chair I didn't hear the vote from
another one ten ten oh and I didn't hear
you vote
no
okay
House Bill uh next uh Bill uh Hospital
125 relative to youth employment during
the school year and at night
representative seaworth you recognize
thank you Mr chairman I would move itl
motion supporters itl second and by
representative Prout
motion has been moved and seconded from
seaworth thank you Mr chairman
um my colleague to my right here uh
expressed his frustration at times I
feel that
um sometimes with this subject he also
showed me how advantageous brevity is
and uh especially when we're getting
ready to go to lunch so I'll I'll try to
consider that less is more
um
is I've made this motion but I can also
count to ten and I know that my motion
will vary
is very likely not to prevail
um and I'll quote the chairman I do
wonder what good it is to pass these
things when we're just going to walk it
over to the Senate and it has no chance
of Passage this is a section of law that
over
the past six eight nine years we have
changed multiple times I count three
four maybe even five changes depending
on how you look at the law and those are
actually bills that pass that change
this law in different ways
um that doesn't count the several bills
that came to us and failed that doesn't
really think about that these went to
study committees they went to
subcommittees they went to retain Bill
committees we've just put a huge amount
of effort into the subject area
and I'm a little perplexed as to why
because it's not one of the big topics
that we usually address
um
I I don't believe this is a good change
to a law that just came into effect last
June and we we really haven't heard any
specifics about how the latest version
of the law isn't working
um I understand that there are
issues with youth employment and always
have been and yes if we ratchet up the
law some more we'll probably get even
more issues with youth employment what
we haven't heard at all is if we change
the law again who will suffer what
teenagers will have trouble with
employment because we've moved the law
relative to their situation so I just
think this is
too much too soon and and there's a lot
of problems with the language which
again in in the last year we went
through a lot of this language there
were numerous amendments to change it it
feels like we've
taken some steps back and forgotten
what's been going on
so for those reasons I've offered itl
thank you representative attitude
thank you Mr chairman
um while I understand to the point that
the vice chairman was making I would
encourage uh the labor committee to not
inherently factor in
um what the other body will do as we all
know you miss 100 of the shots you don't
take
um but as it pertains to the bill if I
recall correctly last year the bill that
we dealt with to deal with the night
work Provisions was a consequence of the
intricate nature and the often confusing
nature of the night work statute and the
Rue Goldberg machine that that
monstrosity was at the time
and the bill that came before us was
basically well this is hard so throw it
all out and uh representative Cahill has
brought before us
um an opportunity to take a look at that
situation and go we were overstepping a
bit and just throwing out uh the vast
majority of night work protections
um
I personally believe that 8 PM is too
late and is the cutoff and I threw a
little bit of a fit about that last year
um so I am happy to compromise
um to representative Cahill's position
and hypothetical Amendment on another
hypothetical motion
um so I would request that the committee
not support this itl
um and instead wait for something better
representative Cahill thank you Mr
chairman
um
see worth and I see some things
differently it appears we see brevity in
different
different degrees but let me let me say
that I was here because that was brief
for him yeah I got you I'm going to do
you know I was here for some of those
changes I I was here when that
monstrosity uh came about and uh at the
request of a particular restaurant tour
uh and it was aggrieved that that was a
mess and when the
former Senator Hennessy brought us a
bill from the other
side it was about expanding the number
of hours from 30 to 35 that wasn't
anything about
night hours fixing it that was something
that was done in this committee and I
think it was an error I think it was too
far
and so what I've done in this bill is to
come up with really pretty good language
that describes when people are in school
and when they're not
and they they can work later
on a Friday night until midnight or
Saturday until midnight or certainly
during their school's vacation week but
nine o'clock
that's really quite enough and we've
also learned uh this I think has been
you know kind of shown to us that the
labor department is not out there
looking at the time clock and making
sure 901 we're going to nail you with a
violation that's not how we roll here in
New Hampshire uh so I I think this is
intended to be better for our students
and easy easier to follow for our
businesses and there is still a small
fly in the ointment in the current
language where somebody could work up 48
hours if the if the uh was only one uh
four days in the school week so we do
need to do something and I think the
language I have here with a minor
Amendment will take will take care of us
my big concern about the bail
is trying to figure out how a
student
can
go through their academic requirements
they're extracurricular requirements
their social requirements
and work more than 15 hours a week
during a school week
however I will support this bill because
it makes a bad Bill a little bit better
for me
and for students
thank you
representative colcum
foreign
I will be supporting itl on this bill
because I do not feel that we should
have to designate a specific time that
students cannot work Beyond
um and not everybody attends public
school
um and each family unit may be different
so some family businesses may be open
past nine o'clock and they may want
their children and allow their children
to work past nine o'clock and they may
feel that their child can handle that
appropriately and I think it's the
parents responsibility to manage what
hours
given hours during the day that their
child can or cannot work
I have nothing against the Restriction
of how many hours cumulative during the
week I do disagree with us mandating
that they must be done at nine the other
thing is there may be some internships
that are available to some of these
students who are focusing in a specific
career path that work Beyond nine
o'clock so this may give them an
opportunity to get involved in an
internship to help with their career
thank you Mr chairman um we've had
discussions about this and I do
understand the
um desire to allow parents to parents
um but there was a former speaker of
this house uh who once told me that
sometimes we don't make laws for the
many we make laws for the few
um and during the public hearing on last
year's bill it was I I'm so mad at
myself that I forgot to write this
answer down because it was the best
example of a question that I asked or I
got exactly the answer that I was
looking for and it was from a
representative of the Department of
Labor and in researching the bill before
us that created this situation I asked
the representative I can't remember if
it was Mr Ogden or not
um but I asked you know does the
Department of Labor get complaints from
parents and his answer was approximately
yeah we do get calls from parents who
are concerned at how late their children
are working and those parents will often
say well I don't want my kid to lose
their job because I think having
employment is good for them I think it
provides them the opportunity to gain
some responsibility and a little bit of
Finance on expertise
um but then those parents get put in the
situation of not necessarily wanting to
go to war with the employer because
they're concerned about what other jobs
might be available for their student if
they lose that and even outside of the
gaining experience and responsibility
angle of it
um they're unfortunately in 2023 still
families where the students have to work
because they're helping to support the
family
um
I I think it's a good Baseline set of
protections there are families where
they have the ability to say you know
what your employer wants you working
until 10 pm you're not doing that we're
pulling you out of that
um because they don't need to get to
work
um but other families feel differently
and would appreciate having a little bit
of that state backstop to say well now
it's not the discretion of the employer
or the family we're removing that
consternation entirely and just saying 9
p.m they gotta go home
they got to go to sleep they got to do
their homework
um and just removing that from the
equation entirely so that's why I'll be
supporting
um a further motion later and not the
my thought would be is in New Hampshire
you have a lot of family-owned
businesses and in this situation like in
restaurants and stuff like that where
the mother and the father run the
business and their children help they
help bust the tables they help wash the
dishes and they help in all different
manners now in this situation
does this remove them
from being able to work in their family
ran business
and in that situation I have to ask
why would we take
a family-run business and say their
you I'm trying to keep it right here
representative Susie was next are you
just gonna answer I don't know if that
was a rhetorical question or an actual
question you want to answer
representative over
it was rhetorical but if there's a good
answer for it I'd appreciate it all
right all right I'm gonna gonna go off
script here but representative Cahill
you're gonna answer followed by
representative Susie uh I'm I'm
certainly open to correction but my
understanding is that the New Hampshire
Department of Labor is basically uh
claim you know uh complaint driven so in
the case of the family business
unless the kid is you know making an
anonymous call saying that I've been
forced to work here and chained to this
uh to this table I don't think this is
going to be an issue here in New
uh this is not a debate you have a what
would you like to state representative
over
no no I'm just I I'd like everyone to
speak but I just I don't want to have a
debate here this is everyone's go ahead
so go ahead
if if if this passes and what Mr Cahill
indicates is true then we're asking them
to break the labor laws by not following
the laws even though no one's calls and
complains or not that's still an act of
representative Jay Silvestro I was going
to ask the labor board to clarify I
thought when it was a family business
the children are allowed to they are
they don't follow the same rules okay so
we need to clarify that and not throw
that in the
country they don't need to have parents
for permission from their whatever like
the school and and whatever so there's a
lot there's a different rule when they
are family members
thank you representative Susie thank you
Mr chairman I'm not going to support the
itl
um
and it kills me and I've told my good
friend Mike Cahill I support some of the
bill
the hours get me
um and for the reasons of
I agree that parents
should be parenting and if they don't
want their children working after nine
o'clock ten o'clock then they don't take
the job
but I will say this if anybody believes
for one second that a 16 17 18 year old
is leaving work at nine o'clock and
going home
I had news for you all right they're
going out they're playing PlayStation
they're doing whatever okay
um that's realistic so again
I'm gonna I'm not gonna support the itl
because I told my good friend Mike
Cahill that I would support him on this
um even though I do not believe in the
hour portion of the law thank you
everybody
and then uh pro thank you Mr chairman um
all of the ideas here today have been um
on topic last year we also changed the
um age that um
employees
that worked in a boring establishment
could
work in that establishment I think we
changed it from 18 to 16.
and I think that this would um
affect those people that are now in
those positions being able to work till
1am in the morning if they so choose or
if the parents so choose or past 12
o'clock on Friday and Saturday or Sunday
nights we changed that law we need to
give the businesses the ability to
schedule those employees that that have
come to a lie on that position thank you
Mr chairman welcome representative Pro
thank you Mr chairman
um I think there's been a lot of focus
on jobs that require you to show up in
person
my high school job was computer
programming I could do it from home
I don't feel the deed that you have to
clock out at 8 59.
when I was already in my bedroom typing
away just now I can't be paid for it
anymore
um and we have to understand that the
law we're considering doesn't
distinguish between those situations at
all
you I think you guys would find it
surprising that
on Labor Day sometimes I used to pick
potatoes in Amherst
and that I used to work in a high school
in a deli
and spit chickens and stuff like that
and there were certain hours but all
came down to it it was parental what my
parents said
between my school work and my athletic
things
and then I had a daughter who became an
LNA while she was a senior at Central
and that required her to work till 11
o'clock at night
during school nights because that was
the the program that they had that was
the only thing available
so it all comes down to it to me I
wouldn't let my child work after 10
o'clock at night on a school night
because that's my choices and my wife
and I's Choice as parents so I don't
even agree with the length of which
you've changed this
um and we have to think of all these
different things
me picking potatoes or me working at a
deli or you working behind the computer
at 10 o'clock at night and all these
other things and
yes I do understand fully representative
attitude unfortunately we do make laws
for that very small percentage
and where we continue to try to bite
around the edges of this and try to make
something perfect we don't have a
perfect society and we don't have a
perfect situation with employment and
and while I respected the attempts to do
so
I think you've gone too far
representative Cahill and this and I
wouldn't agree as a parent on that
believe it or not I wouldn't let my kid
my children work it nor did I uh to some
of those times
um so
um well I applaud the efforts
um
we made some significant significant
changes last year uh not thinking that
everybody liked but some people like
some some didn't like the other
um
but I I I have to in my mind that the
parents have to make decisions and and I
don't and I I
you know sometimes a parent's going to
run a foul of of the or the of the owner
but
I can't make a perfect law
there's no such thing
the emotion on the floor is inexpeding
to legislate
it's been moved seconded if you were in
favor of the motion you'll vote Yes if
you're opposed you'll vote no
uh Mr clerk call the roll thank you Mr
chairman representative seaworth yes
I'll vote Yes representative Prout yes
representative love yes representative
Boyd yes representative Bogart yes
representative colcum yeah
representative Draco yes representative
uh tutor yes
representative Sullivan no
representative Rudy
represent Cahill no representative
Silvestro no representative
Susie no
representative Bouchon no representative
attitude representative Mackenzie no
representative Nettie Wong no and
representative no
10 10 Mr chairman chairman of old chess
uh the motion
um is not successful it's open to
further uh motion representative K he'll
um I have I believe I mentioned during
the uh introduction of the bill that
mistakes are sometimes made and Ms
McGraw has brought to my attention a
mistake that I made in that original
language where I said that uh
much to your understanding that the
people could work until midnight on
Friday and Saturday
well I didn't say midnight I said 12 A.M
and 12 a.m Friday is actually what
happens a moment after 11 59 pm
Thursday
so this amendment which I hope it can be
unanimous on
does change it to no later than midnight
so I would like to move ought to pass
as amended
motion on the floor is
-0328h moved by representative Cahill is
there a second
by representative attitude it's been
moved and seconded
you have the floor if you'd like to you
and I know we're getting late for that
lunch that some people are going to so
I'm I think I've already made my point
as to why this would be helpful
no SeaWorld thank you Mr chairman I am a
little confused though 12 A.M
on Friday is midnight on Friday I would
I would think so this is uh Claire so is
12 a.m on Friday really midnight on
Thursday or or midnight 12 a.m on Friday
is midnight on Saturday that I I
understand the reason for the change it
is a little less confusing what I don't
understand is how it changes the
substance of that sentence
uh it it the the intent is the same but
the language is uh better is clearer so
that it won't be well how do I feel
about 12 a.m on Friday what is how do I
interpret that as compared to how
well you've followed and knows that I
guess I have the same question about if
we don't know what 12 a.m on Friday is
how do we know what midnight on Friday
is because to me they mean the same
thing
just representative kale who brought
would would you like to clarify with
which is the start of Friday
so if you wanted to go to
2359 which would be 11 59 on Thursday to
jump over to zero zero zero zero which
it should be at least clarified in a way
that it should be Friday night into
Saturday and Saturday night into Sunday
is
thank you representative uh well
representative love you had for hit up
first and then representative yeah just
for clarification uh are we voting on
just the amendment uh ocpa just the
amendment representative Mr chairman
could I be indulged to ask two questions
of Representative kale yes uh
representative Cahill
um is it true that uh the Department of
Labor
um often looks to legislative intent
um as well as uh the specific language
of the text of legislation when making
um determinations
thank you for the question I believe
that is correct and I believe that uh if
it's some if something does go to a
hearing you know that a lot of factors
are taken into consideration follow-up I
concur yes so representative Cahill if I
were to hypothetically say into a
microphone and on camera that the thing
that you're aiming for here is for 11 59
pm on Friday and then the next minute
being midnight that being in the cutoff
and the same thing on Saturday could
theoretically the Department of Labor
look at this exact moment in future
videos and say that was representative
Cahill's intent
um for this language as to decry any
confusion
uh thank you Mr uh yes they could and
I'm sure since it is on YouTube it could
be presented as evidence
all right this is uh the motion uh is to
um
uh Amendment
2023-03288 brought by representative
Cahill second and by representative I
forgot representative
thank you
um uh if you are in favor of the uh I
I will just say I will uh before I go
this I apologize I will support your
Amendment
uh so if you're in favor of the
amendment
um
please signify by saying I if you're
opposed nay Mr clerk please call the
roll
thank you Mr chairman representative
I'll be voting yes representative proud
yes representative yes representative
Boyd yes representative
yes representative cocom yes
representative Draco yes representative
Tudor yes representative Sullivan yes
representative Rudy yes representative
Cahill yes representative Silvestro yeah
representative Susie yes representative
Bouchon yes representative attitude yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Cincinnati Wong yes
representative yes
and the chair
watch yes
chair recognizes representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and I would like to
move uh lots of pass on HB 125 as
amended
most is uh made ought to pass by
representative Cahill second by
representative Sullivan representative
Cahill you're uh recognized to speak to
motion uh thank you Mr chairman again we
uh we are trying we are striving for
Perfection or at least that which is
clearly understood and beneficial to as
many people uh in the industry in the
working public this is protective
legislation and you know if I think back
to my 16 year old self there might be a
few things I'd like to tell that person
uh so that they would not do some of the
things that they did or didn't do uh we
we certainly rely on parents and we also
rely on employers to be responsible and
not to have people working late into the
night and yet I do see sometimes see
those violations not for a minute past
or three minutes past but lengthy
violations and and certain other uh
violations too so it does happen in the
world and I know that this is probably
not something that happens with the
association's members but again we are
regulating all the people who hire young
people and for that reason I am voting
me another I think everyone knows how
they're going to vote if you are in
favor of the motion you'll be uh voting
yes if you're opposed to the ought to
pass you'll be voting no
clerk you may call the roll yeah one
I have been so corrected
um the emotion on the floor is ought to
pass with Amendment if you're in favor
of voting yes if you're opposed no thank
Mr chairman a quick question yes
um
so we would have to move OTP in order to
have the amendment so the motion would
the last motion would be OTP and with
the adoption of the amendment and then
we passed the
we passed the amendment I'm just looking
on here for what we need to fill in
because it says otpa or or adoption of
amendment
the first vote was the amendment correct
okay the second the this
would be ought to pass with Amendment
thank you
you got the hot seat today yeah I do
thank you so I appreciate you doing it
because I don't want to do it
representative seaward didn't want to do
representative C what no
however no representative Prout no
representative love no representative
Boyd go representative poker
no
Representative kokom no representative
Draco
representative tutor no representative
Sullivan yes represent varudi yes
representative Cahill yes representative
Silvestro yeah representative Susie
representative Bouchard yes
representative abigin yes representative
McKenzie representative
yeah representative yes and the chair
I know
thank you
10 10 Mr chairman thank you
is there any other business in front of
this committee
thank you to our uh our uh
Folks at filled in today thank you very
much for your service to the labor
committee uh we'll have some committees
this afternoon and
um and um we'll be you'll be hearing
from me one more uh time for a
scheduling of our final uh executive
committee please have the uh the
committee reports to Representatives or
to me uh or representative Sullivan
um
by Monday please
and Mr chairman the report on uh HB 561
will be adjutant the report on
hb150 will be myself and the report on
125 will be Cahill
all right
thank you very much folks go to your go
go run over to the get up get your lunch
thank you very as always thank you folks
today
uh we'll open the subcommittee on HB
232fn
do not do it
okay
sure please representative
okay here we go
the subcommittees are typically informal
and I would like to
I think we would like to maintain that
tradition so a give and take within the
committee and uh within the folks who
are here to share their thoughts and
expertise will be uh welcome
um two issues that uh uh came up during
the hearing that I think weren't uh let
me back up
um the the chairman wanted to have this
subcommittee to make sure that any
um issues that need tweaking or
adjusting
are taken care of and don't become
impediments as we go forward with the
process because I believe that
um
the chair and the
members of these study group from the
summer are committed to getting these
safety standards in place and if there's
something that we need to manage in
order to make that happen
um we'll uh
do our best to manage that so with that
the two issues that came up that I think
are worthy of
addressing up front
were concerns about 20 28a unfunded
mandates and also the um
the effective date and I've discussed
that with Deputy Commissioner Ogden and
if the Deputy Commissioner is available
to come to the mic that would be
fantastic
good afternoon
we we can start with the 28 a and I'll
and actually I'll start with it because
representative Mckenzie was uh kind
enough to do some research on this and
did find a Supreme Court case that
um dispelled the idea that any
additional costs that happen anywhere
anytime due to a change in a program
would give rise to a 28a issue
New Hampshire has been doing safety
inspections and has been implementing
safety standards for many years and what
this bill will do will it will find it
will
make more clear what those safety
standards are because essentially the
OSHA standards have been sort of the de
facto standards here without them being
officially in place with that said
Deputy Commissioner go ahead
yeah so in terms of I think this issue
has come up in the past when I say this
issue has come up in the past is
typically when we've talked about our
safety standards or our enforcement of
those standards we have oftentimes come
across questions related to 28a
specifically the Department's ability uh
to compel compliance with things and how
compelling compliance in certain
instances uh attributes costs or uh you
know puts costs upon municipalities or
cities and towns
um in terms of I'm not representative
McKenzie the specific citation I'm I
don't have that off the top of my head
but I am aware in a general sense of the
fact that what 28 a is talking about is
new or added costs or added programs uh
not previously contemplated or not
previously in place as I've said in the
past when we've talked about these
safety standards it's absolutely
arguable someone could say that when you
put new standards in place you're adding
costs and then adding costs that are on
funded did that presents constitutional
problems that argument could be made the
argument was made when we put reporting
requirements in place into RSA 277 a
couple sessions ago similar arguments
were made that now you're adding new
reporting requirements in terms of these
cities and towns are going to have to
comply with these that might incur costs
is that a constitutional violation so
that's kind of a long and tortured way
of saying that this has come up in the
past it's something that could be
challenged or could be uh you know
people arguing about it or or making
their concerns known as you say
representative Sullivan that RSA 277
which the department is enforced you
know for some time it does presently
require that public employers provide a
safe workplace it does presently require
that public employers put in place
safeguards sufficient to provide a safe
workplace and again that's where I think
that there is some sentiment out there
that okay is this truly a new change or
is this just added or more explicit uh
underlining or outlining of what those
requirements are again I do think it's
something worth talking about thinking
about because it ultimately could be
challenged but again this is something
that's come up and been talked about in
the past relative to our existing
application of law
do other members of the subcommittee
have questions or thoughts along those
lines
yep
um
do we need to do this in law can you is
the department able to do and adopt
these mandates without us telling you to
in part and what what I mean by that is
that my earlier testimony when the bill
was initially introduced I did reference
the Department's existing use and
application of the general duty Clause
so under RSA 277 there's specific uh
statutory Authority for the Department
to say to employers you need to provide
a safe workplace that's also put in line
RSA 281 a64 where again public employers
are told that they have to provide safe
employment because the department can
require safe employment and has some
rulemaking Authority relative to those
requirements we can put in place
standards that say you need to do this
you need to do that relative to your
operation of your organization I think
where the department sometimes struggles
is that in order to go through rule
making and to say okay you know we need
to adopt you know this whole Litany of
Standards there could be questions in
terms of whether is okay are are what we
have in place already sufficient do you
truly need to extend beyond what's in
place already so could we pass
regulations in addition to what we
presently have without this Bill yes
would we be able to pass the whole host
of standards that are present place
under OSHA I'm not sure I think that you
could see challenges to that relative to
oh
um so
you could do part of it but let's say
there was an accident
on a bridge that the state was taking
care of
um would you reference if you didn't
have a reference in your rules or
anything relating to bridge bridge
safety would you be referring to 1910 or
OSHA standards in that case no without
this change what we would do what we
currently do is if we investigate a
safety incident or we're doing an
inspection as part of our overall safety
audit we see something that seems unsafe
but we don't have a particular statute
or regulation exactly on point we would
cite what I would refer to earlier as
the general duty Clause the general duty
Clause says and public employers are
supposed to provide safe employment
they're supposed to put safeguards in
place that's what we would cite now and
then we would have to have that
discussion over what that is at times we
do look to 1910 because we say okay
that's something that's out there at
other times we just look to more General
uh even if it's not specifically in 1910
if there's like an industry standard
that's out there and seeming has
widespread adoption that might be
another thing that we reference under
the general duty Clause but again
presently without those safety uh
without 1910 specifically or explicitly
adopted we're citing the general duty
clause and then we're kind of backing
into in order to meet that general duty
Clause the employer should do the
following or should account for the
following types of things so sometimes
we're looking at 1910 but we do not have
could you adopt that without us telling
you to do that in those certain
instances where it's not easily defined
within your current
through administrative rulemaking we
could attempt to do that
thank you and the in When you mention
the industry standard as opposed to
General Judy is that the Private
Industry standard or the the industry
standard yeah when I say industry
standard there I'm talking about just
you know what commonly is happening you
know that if if people in that field
would you know you go to 100 job sites
that's happening at all of those job
sites
so let's just say it's a lack of safety
goggles something like that I mean again
those are probably be specifically
within a 1910 we even have something on
safety eyewear but yes something like
that where it's just generally
widespread adopted throughout the
industry
or Industries
thank you and then the for the
implementation
um
hello
oh there we go
um just out of curiosity because this
question came up I think to myself and
representative Sullivan
if this was to become law
are you familiar with NFPA standards
National Fire Protection Agency
standards yeah I've heard so
under this would because I know there's
some concern probably with small
departments as to the two in two out
rule
um
which is an NFPA standard but I'm
wondering if this would apply under the
OSHA standards which
basically in a nutshell says that two if
there's two going in which is the
standard there has to be two outside and
there are some exceptions to the rule
um but I'd have to go back and see what
the exceptions are I don't know if you
have an answer for that if I could look
at that specific issue off the top of my
you'd have to have four firefighters or
four members of that department to allow
you to go in the building
or maybe if there's two going in there's
got to be two outside of NFPA two went
I think there's a distinction here
between culture and and yeah that's what
I'm trying to find skin okay as there is
I I did have a conversation with and I
wish I could remember his name offhand
uh Mr chairman
I
um do you recall who who the gentleman
was from the fire uh I don't know if it
was Fire Chiefs or exactly who but uh he
I think he called you or he contacted
you and he actually called me do you
recall
foreign
I do not recall the name I recall
getting the message I recall passing it
on to you
um it was from Bedford that Bedford
police chief that's who it was fire fire
Bedford fire police and basically the
conversation we had was that apparently
this two in two out is somehow embedded
in the OSHA standards and uh uh you know
he he felt that it was uh a rule that
was sufficiently exceptioned that uh if
if effects if if a firefighter showed up
if he was first on the scene and no one
else was showing up and he saw a kid
waving their hands out the window
um life in danger that firefighter would
do what needed to be done
um but um if uh so I'm not an expert on
it but that's how it was explained to me
so
um I'll I'll leave it at that because I
have nothing to do with firefighting
um but um
anything else on 28a from the committee
or the uh
okay
um sorry did you read the letter that
came in from Margaret burns from the
um
let's move on to the uh
effective date
there were some
concerns raised at the hearing about the
if the if the effective date is 60 days
after passage that on the 61st day there
would be violations being cited and
fines being doled out across the state
that's probably an overstatement of the
concern but it was that's probably the
extreme view of the concern Deputy
Commissioner could you Enlighten us as
to how the department would would deal
with
the expansion or the more specific
standards that the OSHA 1910 would
provide and how
the department would operate on the 61st
day the 82nd day the 90th day and so on
what how would you operate how would you
deal with public sector employers and
the the
build up into the 1910 standards
so in in terms of practical
implementation
upon the effective date so if you reach
day 60 that would be the existing
standard any inspection following that
date uh would we would be seeking
compliance with those standards and what
I mean by that is it's not that if on
day 60 then we immediately open up an
inspection on every city and town in the
state all at once and say okay you guys
are behind and here are the fines and
penalties
rather our practice would remain the
same that we're following up on
petitions we're following up on injury
incident reports we're following up on
complaints and when we follow up on
those things we apply the applicable law
so again day 65 we would be saying okay
here are the existing standards we would
be looking at the 19 10 standards
I don't imagine our practice would not
change in terms of remediation and what
I mean by that is most of our safety
inspections
um they're kind of uh if there are
findings it's the beginning of a process
and what I mean by that is when we find
that there is a violation or something
that needs to be corrected it's then
working with the employer to say okay
what's your plan for coming into
compliance there are some instances if
it was an immediate uh threat where you
know you have something that's likely to
cause serious harm or injury in the
immediate we could say okay that has to
stop all at once that has to be
corrected all at once but many times
what you're dealing with are things in
which we're seeking corrective measures
or an adjustment of actions or ongoing
operations and that's something again
where we typically look at it as a
remediation period so in terms of if
you're asking how would this roll out
upon effective date those would be the
applicable standards that's what we
would apply in the context of an
inspection when we cite something we
would then be seeking what's the plan
for remediation of the employer and some
of these plans for remediation they can
be somewhat elongated because we do
understand that there are things that
have to happen before Corrections can be
made so when we work with state agencies
or we work with cities and towns again
we're coming up with if there's problems
here are the problems what is what is a
solution or what can you guys do to come
to the solution and then how long is
that going to take and we're looking for
reasonableness in terms of a plan we
don't want to say okay they're going to
wait three years but we understand that
at what point do the fines come into
play
so typically what would happen in the
context of an inspection is if we cite
something there might be an initial
assessed penalty where we'd say okay
here's some type of penalty that is held
uh
in abeyance throughout that remediation
period and again really the fines it's
not a revenue generator or anything like
that we typically don't really find the
cities and towns or other state agencies
it's just something that is like I said
it's ultimately out there
typically held in abandons through the
remediation period if we had no
follow-up or follow through or if we've
had repeated violations where you know a
city or a town
has not done something and then we are
back there and they're still not doing
it
um that's where there might be penalties
but again typically the penalties are
put out there in order to incentivize or
is it fair to say that your process with
regard to safety violations is more of
an educational one than a punitive one
yeah that's the hope I mean again
certainly I don't I don't view our
safety program as something where we're
generating Revenue we don't see the
penalties as a revenue generator or
um
so let's say we we put this through uh
this year so typically all the bills
would be done by the end of June would
you be ready to go on September 1st to
enforce all these
so this was a discussion I think we had
had towards the talent of the study
committee there would certainly be a
learning curve for us but I do think in
terms of what we'd apply yes we could I
think going forward we'd be in a
position to say okay anything we come
across here's the standards we're going
to look to
um and to be fair it's something that
we've had our inspectors uh looking at
probably for the past two or three years
we've increasingly looked uh towards
OSHA standards for a variety of reasons
um but that's a long way of saying that
I think in terms from enforcement or
understanding what we would be enforcing
yes
um I think we would have to do a lot of
work in terms of putting together
educational materials I don't think
that's something where I think that
we're not there yet and what I mean by
that is if an employer came to us right
out and said give us good documentation
for training that's something that we
would have to work towards developing so
that's where I think the most work would
be is in terms of the department
developing Educational Tools to hand out
or provide I think that would be the
biggest thing but in terms of
enforcement I think enforcement we would
we would be able to say okay we
understand what the standards would be
so if
we uh maybe we put a lead in say that
the bill goes into effect yet there's a
12-month lead-in for educational
purposes or anything else before fines
or fees or something else goes into
effect or
because we have a lot of little towns
that already got the this month are
going to pass their budgets and they're
not going to have ability to do change
do much change before next march or even
the following year if there's not an
issue that's found during that you know
preceding the budget season
um could the wording that you'd like to
see that there's some type of leading
for educational purposes and I have a
follow-up
with the would the department want to
fund some of that educational purposes
or would they need an appropriation
yeah I mean in terms of we'd be happy to
provide any training that we could
provide um I think I referenced in my
testimony for the initial bill this is
not envisioning like setting up a
consultancy program that's something
that we're we're not setting up that I
think would require
additional funding
um
again I I in terms of putting in a
lead-in period i i defer to you know you
guys in terms of what makes sense for
that
um again I would highlight the fact that
when it becomes effective uh I I don't
know I would def you know I don't know
how cities and towns or state agencies
even for that matter would necessarily
uh best be situated you know when
they're going to start looking at this
stuff if they start looking at this
stuff uh so again I defer to you on
whether there's benefit to a lead-in
period
and I guess I want to be clear that I
if there's a good reason to to modify
the um uh the effective date
I for one uh feel like that's that's
fine we should do it and I think as a
subcommittee we need to talk it through
it and and frankly what representative
avalani is talking about is uh
uh
would be far better than just simply
saying the effective date is one year
after
um passage because if if you say that
then the um
the day after the one year is up would
be just like the 61st day if you had a
60 day
um
uh effective date so I think if
something's going to happen to make
folks more comfortable and more informed
about uh any more specific oceans
um 1910 standards
that sounds good but if all people are
going to do is wait because it's not
happening yet and nothing happens for a
year it's just a year wasted so that
makes no sense but um
I mean if I can see an upside and I hear
what you're saying about the fine that
basically you um
you put a 2500 fine or some fine in
place at the at the front end of a
violation and then never collect it if
people are diligent about uh coming into
compliance
um do you think it would be more
comfortable for the public employers if
that fine wasn't there if you simply
said you know the inspectors were
directed
to inform all public employers
of what the new standards will be
um
with no
um action to take no punitive action
um possible until after one year is done
do you think that would be
um
possibly again I I do think that
I I think that
possibly that could make folks more
comfortable
thank you Mr chairman
there seems to be two the only two
issues that come up
against this
in my opinion is
um
a fear of not understanding and a cost
so
um trying to think back from all the
things you said most Town meetings are
in March
if you enacted a bill
you have
um
in
the latter part of because you know
let's be honest it's going to get past
if it gets passed and it's June right
we're sitting here in June
I mean
from September to December the
Department of Labor
does some roving Road shows
and
um to explain what 1910 is for some what
things will be required it gives them
also time to put their own rules in
place because they're you know we we
send them a law congratulations have a
good day someone's got a
figure out the rules and what they're
doing
it allows people in the latter part of
the year to know what if anything they
need to purchase
that can be part of town meeting and
then they can acquire what they need
learn how to use it and it becomes
effective June 1st
I like a timeline like like that I'm not
sure we need to
um actually put anything into the
statute
to
state that they can't find anyone for a
year
I have maybe maybe I'm off my rocker
here but I have a lot of faith in the
Department of Labor
that they're not going to find anyone in
the first six months as they're trying
to work their way through this I I just
I unlike other states our department of
labor is more of a teaching mechanism
department to get these these people to
do it right the first time I think if
maybe they went to a municipality they
continue to not do something
uh for a year in a row and if they stop
by three times they would probably do
something so I don't know if I want to
put that in the well you can make a
agreement with the commissioner that we
don't want them to do that well my
intent wasn't to say there will be no
fines because I think uh Rudy would
readily say that for egregious
violations of current standards the
department would be right on top of it
and would take whatever action is
necessary to make things safe
but if we made the implementation
um I think what you're suggesting is
make it a year out right it also allows
us to do this we passed this thing in
June or the governor whoever signs it or
doesn't signs it in June
and they have these Road shows in the
latter part of the year
it allows for a situation where
something comes up that we didn't know
whoops we didn't see that
thing that you know I I've tried to read
that voluminous thing uh it you know I
you know geez it's better than a
sleeping pill
um the um and I'm still reading it
because I I I I I want to know exactly
we then have the first six three or four
months of next year if we have to tweak
something
before it goes into place on June
30th if you will of 24.
and if there's something let's say we
find out there's something in there
that
none of the towns have and the only
place to get this thing
cost each Town twenty five thousand
dollars we may have to you know scratch
our head on something like that
what do you call the
confined space
the lifts that have to be in the outside
and pull someone in you guys know what
those are called
mark
Tim no no clue so if anyone goes into
confined space
you have to have this harness on them
and it has to have a tripod outside
where someone's there to pull them up
and all this other stuff those aren't
cheap
um
I don't think they're exorbitant that's
the best example I can come up with
right now of something that could be a
that if all of a sudden we find out
through supply chain issues no one can
get them
but one would hope that if they're that
important and for safety they've already
got them one hope
so I'm just saying it gives us a
timeline and it gives a comfort level
that we have 90 days to get the
municipalities on board to find out what
it is for people to come back to us and
say yeah this is okay but this is a
problem
if we have to make a change we can in
the first quarter of of next year but
implementation as of you know June 30th
of 24. you I don't care what you do with
the fines that's up to you guys what you
feel comfortable with
so I agree with just about everything he
said the exception of the date so I
would go July 1st because of schools no
because of school school budgeting I
think most of our schools if not all of
our schools and their fiscal period ends
on June 30th so um to get it into their
budget timeline properly June July 1st
yeah
because quite frankly I want to hear I'm
a Hillsborough guy
Hillsborough County and during testimony
Hillsborough
there's a lobbyists Hillsborough County
you know either nursing home or whatever
said this is going to cost us
an exorbitant amount of money
and um just in case we're wrong on
something and someone else is right it
supply chain issue for 200 pounds
getting the same piece of equipment and
numerous state agencies
would there be some
leeway with that
with the department and say everybody's
ordering just say safety goggles at the
same time and there's a obviously going
to be a shortage of 200 towns are
looking for five or ten twenty pairs
each and
they can't get enough for four five six
months will the department work with
them on that as well
yeah I mean obviously we would the facts
of each case we'd have to look at but in
a general sense the department always
tries to work with folks and we
understand you know practical and you
know reality we understand that there's
limitations sometimes in terms of what's
realistic I only caution by saying fact
intensive because we would want to look
at if there's a certain problematic
practice that you know someone was going
to be
you know potentially you know losing a
limb or their life and it's like okay
but you know we can't correct that until
we get this piece of equipment we would
probably say okay well that we there's
only a penalty but that activity should
stop you understand what I'm saying is
we would you know we certainly work with
folks but there might be instances in
which you'd have to say part of working
with them would be okay no penalties and
we'll let you take some time to come
into compliance but the activity itself
has to stop or be edited
um in the interim
so some
let's say to some safety bar on a
transfer station before they throw their
trash into the compactor would would the
department
give them leeway to fix that or they
would shut down that
compactor because there was a missing
safety box again in most instances there
is leeway provided the time where there
would not be leeway provided as if it's
looked at as like an immediate or
emergent
um
life or limb type scenario thank you and
some of the 1910 required certifications
in certain areas
how would that apply to
um
I hate to say comment contracts that you
already have with your employees
um would there be additional
negotiations that would need to take
place because certain employees need to
have certain certifications because of a
supervisory role or a just the type of
job that they have
um things of that nature yeah ultimately
you'd be looking for those individuals
to get the proper certification or
licensure to perform those those uh
those activities and does that end up
potentially resulting in uh some type of
adjustment relative to those employees
possibly
the
so the question I got was if there is
specific
testing that needs to be done and let's
say the person that's supervising the
transfer station just can't pass that
test
and they happen to be on a collective
bargaining thing or a part of a union
would the employer be able to
make that change without violating the
CBA because they can't pass that test
because of the implementation that we
did
so I mean again that's a highly specific
example uh in a lot of instances I
believe there
I could see I see where your question is
coming from I think a lot of times
though that uh even within the confines
of a collectively bargained agreement
there's some understanding that job
duties might change and uh
again that's a very specific example I
can understand where the concern is
coming from
um
having dealt with collective bargaining
agreements and changes in the law I'm
aware that if
the laws change it makes something in
the collective bargaining agreement
by in violation of a law
that piece of the collective bargaining
agreement is null and void I'm happy to
remember back in when I was first
starting to negotiate teaching contracts
um smoking was a was a thing in schools
um and I was very grateful when the law
was passed saying smoking indoors will
not be a thing
um and we've stopped filing grievances
over teachers not being allowed to smoke
so that was that was a happy day for me
but I would suggest the same thing would
happen if there's something in a
collective bar agreement or past
practice that's in place that becomes in
violation of
the safety standards
then the the standards would uh would
would Trump the contract I would agree
with that I think where I'm somewhat
with representative avalani's question
is I I do see that there could be
scenarios in which someone has a job
their job is in the CBA their their
sjd's been approved and now you're
saying they might have to do this
additional thing and if they can never
do that additional thing what happens to
their position or what happens to their
their job and things of that nature
those sometimes things like that I can
imagine coming out but that's a highly
specific example
um I don't off the top of my head
exactly know how that would uh
shake out typically the employer does
have the wherewithal they have to meet
their obligations with the law so
um I believe there'd be some allowances
the question that came up was cost as
well
um there was thoughts of adding an FN to
this for a
um
uh sorry
adding a distribution of the general
fund to
um offset some of the costs some of
these municipalities and towns would
have
um
we can't do that now
the department allocates some funds for
educational materials and I know you
approached that but and other materials
as well if they had to rewrite their
employee manuals to incorporate some of
these standards or Personnel manuals
be amenable to offsetting some of those
costs if the if there was a
process where they could say Hey you
know we don't know how to write these
so we would certainly mean
we would certainly be willing to assist
any public employer in terms of doing
that in terms of actually providing
dedicated services or costs we're not
presently uh or reimbursement you know
someone wanted to hire someone to do it
were not presently set up to reimburse
for those costs when I say not presently
set up we don't have a budget line right
now where I could basically have a
revolving fund saying okay submit your
expenditures and you can be reimbursed
we do not have that that's not set up in
our present budget in terms of providing
assistance we'd be happy to provide
assistance uh if someone was asking you
know for us to review things asking for
suggestions or things of that nature but
I understand that that's more informal
and not as comprehensive of what you're
you're speaking to but in terms of what
you're speaking to we're not presently
would we be able to
um would the given that this is a budget
year would the commissioner be able to
do that
outside of the budget if he was if this
plan was to come in and let's say we
were doing it in 24
um would he be able to ask for a
revolving fund but maybe fund it with
some of the
um monies that the department takes in
to a certain amount and you know be
reimbursable for 50 of your cost for
implementing this program or something
like that something like OSHA does when
they have their plan as they rebate some
of the costs could the department do
I can ask I mean in terms of off-cycle
uh setting up lines or new lines I can
ask what the ability would be to do
something like that I also don't know in
terms of are you envisioning
um you know reimbursement capped at a
certain amount or I guess I would want
to know perhaps more about the
parameters relative to it what I mean by
that is is it something where they could
come in and say you know we need uh X
thousand dollars for for what so is it
for any added costs is it for
consultancy costs
I would probably say just related to the
implementation of the program whether it
be employee manuals whether it be
offsetting some of the costs for larger
purchases for safety equipment things
like that up to a certain amount that
the department would be willing to do
that I mean if it's they could count for
the ten thousand per town or ten
thousand per department or you know a
hundred thousand total or a million
dollars total over the life of three
years or obviously we would
throw around some numbers down the road
but I don't know if that would be
something that he would be interested in
if you know where I'm going yeah I mean
ultimately I think we would need
legislation like I said I will ask about
uh the uh whether through fiscal
Committee Action outside of the budget
would it even be possible like next year
I can ask about that long term I
ultimately think if you were going to
try and set up some type of fun like
this you would want legislation to
basically say this is what the fund is
this is how it's funded this is how
requests are made of the fund this is
how uh requests are processed so
ultimately I think you would want
legislation for that but I I will ask
about this off cycle you know is this
something we could go to fiscal
you know next year and say uh you know
can we move money from this line to this
newly established line I'm not sure what
the options are for doing that outside
of the budget development that we're
presently going through uh but I will
I know we've got someone here from
administrative Services
um well I think has been trying to flag
down my attention we also have Susie
Nord here from National Kosh I know
she's brought some materials for the
committee so
do you have questions for the uh
everybody
yeah why don't you go share Mike with uh
I'm sorry I don't remember your name
that's okay um my name is Joyce Pittman
I'm the director of risk and benefits
with the Department of administrative
services
and as the service agency for all of the
agencies in the state
um and I'm going to just be really
honest in this casual environment we
would need to assess what that exactly
means I think we have some state
agencies that are more advanced and what
we're talking about when we say OSHA and
we have others that aren't so I would
have questions like who am I going to
work with in agencies and I'm not saying
that we don't I'm not against any of
this employee safety we also run the
workers compensation program for the
state
so anything that protects our employees
we're for it but we want to do it right
and what I see is the Department of
Labor is working this way
to try to get us to ensure we're doing
it right and provide that consultancy
and education but we want to be prepared
for them and we own that all of our
agencies need to know okay I have this
new
uh regulation I have to comply with
where am I now and where do I need to be
who am I going to dedicate for my staff
to do it do I need to hire an external
consultant to come in and teach us
what do I need to do and when you were
talking about the leeway I think that's
a great question because I'm thinking
the same thing but I'm thinking I'm not
even sure what the municipalities have
for Staffing to make this this needs to
be a big deal you know it has to be a
priority and I think we're all fairly
thinly staffed with people doing their
regular jobs to add this not that it's
not important but they need to know what
they're doing they need to have the
budget they need to do it strategically
so they're checking the boxes and then
working in conjunction with the
Department of Labor so we meet in the
middle
do you know what I mean like we want we
want to do it right we're going to raise
the bar and get there what do you need
and then for us being the service agency
what do our agencies need how far off
are they some of them may have these
harnesses some of them may not even
realize they have confined spaces
isn't that a bigger challenge
so and I think that's we do work with
the Department of Labor now we do work
on these things so I don't think it's
the wild west of unsafiness if that's a
word out there but you're you're putting
more standards in place and we'd want to
do it right right and and I guess that
was the point I was thinking of making
is that it's not as if there's are no
safety standards now correct um there
are safety standards some of them are
being sort of Unwritten safety standards
um creates an unfair circumstance for
any employer or employee if you if it's
not written but you're expected to live
up to it because it's unsafe and it
comes it would fall under the general
duties Clause
um then um this should be a great help
to people and I think if we give some
lead-in time which I think is
I'm getting comfortable with that idea
that would provide the agencies
um the municipalities and so on with
some time to work with the Department of
Labor to work internally to figure all
of this out and and again
knowing that we're working with our
department of labor not somebody else's
Department of Labor and knowing how they
operate that they come in and they
um
they're a fixing organization not a you
know punishing organization so
um I I think we can make this work
um especially with that lead-in time and
um
I I'm hopeful right and you see what I
mean by coming in the middle like the
agencies and the municipalities the
towns they have to figure out what's
expected of them
rely on the Department of Labor to tell
us what that is
is that fair
yeah I think that that is one issue in
terms of
we are happy to try and work with anyone
to educate them but we're not going to
necessarily have the opportunity to
give everyone here is everything and
explain what every what each piece of it
means how that oftentimes comes up now
is in the context of you're doing a
safety inspection you're like okay this
was off but I that's why I would agree
with what um director Pittman is saying
in that
yeah we're
we would not necessarily were not
equipped to tell everyone and I don't
think we ever will be to tell everybody
in every city in town here's what
everything means and here's how you're
gonna do it and like so there'll be no
problems that just just hire another 300
people yeah yeah
no so I think that's a great point is I
yeah and I also would say
um
there are agencies right now sorry there
are agencies right now that do have
dedicated safety staff in place
um that are doing that other agencies
you are having it done more as a HR
function or a director of administration
type function so it does differ and
again I would defer um the
municipalities I imagine is also
somewhat where some have like a whole
safety sector and and some don't well I
would imagine that some agencies have
fewer safety concerns
if most of your folks are office workers
then
there's not as much of a safety concern
is if you're operating heavy equipment
yeah I mean I think they're different
concerns and I think that um yeah there
are certain agencies where I would say
the host of our traffic at least
and oddly if you look at our workers
compensation claims our biggest offender
or slips and false
yep that parking lot
yep
um the question I have is uh
the state does its own Bridge work on
some bridges we all drive over them what
standards do they follow now
so Department of Transportation I mean
there are uh some other but I'll speak
specifically the Department of
Transportation uh they do follow they
again they look at industry standards
best practices things of that nature
they have dedicated safety compliance
folks if you talk to the folks from dot
they will tell you most of their folks
have some connection or background to
OSHA the folks that they've hired are
familiar with OSHA standards and that's
typically what they're trying to apply
would it be fair to say that most of
this would hinge on dot employees and
not really office workers per se
police fire have their own standards
yeah so in terms of I mean I think that
I would say I don't think that the 1910
standards themselves are going to
present a whole host of like new added
complexity to the office environment the
general office environment I would agree
with that I would think that a lot of
the
um more Market changes are probably
related to work site type activities
um I I believe that that's generally
true and then with a lot of the
municipalities and stuff you're talking
about they have tool sheds or different
tools they're working with where again
we might see that in some of our
agencies they have you know where they
have folks doing that type of work
um yeah that's probably where the the
host of the impact is I don't think that
it's a huge Market change for the
general office worker
and this will be my last one
um can I just add to that though when I
said that we're over the state and I
said where the department of
administrative services I don't mean
that we only focus on the administrative
services that are in agencies Das also
manages all of General services so we
are the facilities workers in all of the
state-owned properties across the state
and there's a lot of different safety
implications of that type of work when
you're doing the construction and and
all of that involved in these buildings
so the from the facilities aspect you
would have on staff electricians you
would have on staff plumbers you would
which also follow their own
electrical code plumbing code HVAC and
everything else would the 1910 increase
those standards or would it be basically
mirroring what's already in place
for us that's the analysis I would want
to help them do
so I don't I can't answer I think yeah
there's
so typically again how an inspection
would work now is if we went into a city
or town or a state agency and they and
they were doing their own electrical
work and that's important because a lot
of times when we go into places they've
hired a contractor and if the contractor
is a private employer we're not doing
that at all right but if we went into a
place where they're doing their own
electrical work we would certainly
leverage the electrical standard you
know the standards for doing electrical
work we would look at that but then
there's more generalized what do you do
on a work site what do you do like if
you have things hanging what do you do
if you're
um that with 1910 I do think you're
going to see some changes to those again
more of the to Joyce's point about
people doing work and construction yes
there are go and when I say work in
construction not only building buildings
but like yeah like putting up a wall or
digging a trench things like that I do
so I know I'm going over your time I'm
sorry the um so if you had a private
employer come in to do the same job that
a public employer was doing right now
they would be held to two different
standards
correct I mean if if we if we're going
to like a municipality and they've hired
an electrician and the electrician is
not their employee that's not governed
by us the only time that sometimes it
comes I'm not trying to get into the
weeds with this but if if the people who
work in the office are like going
through that job site we would look at
it and say okay that job site has to be
in some way secure and safe for the
municipal workers working around it but
we're not dealing with the electrician
that's the private entity understood
watching your time and knowing that uh
Ms Nord is here and just brought us some
materials would you uh like to address
foreign
TV or not
I'm not sure if we're being youtubed or
not maybe we are maybe we aren't all
right well
um so basically what I did my
organization manages a list serve with
about 2 500
industrial hygienesis or people with you
know Public Health backgrounds
especially the occupational aspect of it
and I put out a question about what does
it cost a public employer to implement a
health and safety program that would be
OSHA compliant
and there is no good answer for that for
the reasons which have pretty much been
discussed here
um it really depends on which employer
you're talking about how far along they
already are what they're doing what you
know what things they Outsource what
things that they they do themselves so
um I even went as far as speaking I've
tracked down a professor at the
University of Indiana in Pennsylvania
who did a report similar to the one that
we did last summer
who did do some State information
at the state level talking to their
administrative Services probably
compatriots and
chose a handful of departments
um
she that report isn't publicly available
so I wasn't able to get it but I will
say that there's a link on there that's
not available online the one for the
Massachusetts report there's a copy of
it that I just gave representative
Sullivan if anybody would like it my
email is on that paper there's a a
a table with maybe 10 15 examples of
injuries at the at a state department
one that they mentioned was a trip and
fall and what the remedy would be under
OSHA and for example the trip and fall
one I happen to remember it's kind of
weird that you mentioned that was that
they were recommended that they paint
wherever the thing was that the person
tripped on so that the actual cost of
remediation to be in compliance with
what OSHA would say they do was some
paint and the time to paint it
um
I'm not sure how helpful that is in
terms of getting something actually
started however I do know that
I before I lived in Concord I lived in
Candia which is your prototypical small
town we had a road agent I think most of
his projects if he couldn't do it were
subcontracted so then they weren't part
of this wouldn't be covered by this but
I will say that we also because we were
such a small town and the selectman you
know it's not a full-time job I was on
the planning board I didn't know a whole
lot about planning until I became on the
planning board but they we hire we sort
of have a contract with at that point it
was Southern New Hampshire Planning
Commission and I believe this is the
kind of thing that select boards and
towns do if they're small like Candia is
the municipal Association if you're a
member of the municipal Association they
keep you up to date on changes that you
need to know about so that's part of how
Candia as a small town with very minimal
budget very low taxes
um and we were proud and kept them that
way
um but that's how we did it was that we
had we had we spent the the money to
just do the bare minimum that we needed
to do and so
this for a town like Candia there might
be some jump in what they would have to
do but they're also so small they don't
even have a Department of Public Works
they have a road agent and truthfully I
would be interested to know how a road
agent is covered by this or not
so
um is he an employee of the town if he's
an elected official so there's all kinds
of questions and I understand why you
are all asking them
I will say that if you want to get it
get to a number you're never going to
get that number we could fund a study
and somebody could go to all 400 towns
and cities how many school districts how
many public services like police fire
every state agency is that really going
to happen I don't think so and that's
the only way to get the number so what
I've given you to get back to what I
gave you was all of the financial
information I was inundated with when I
put this question out which doesn't
actually answer that question but it
does tell you why this makes good fiscal
sense why it is good public policy why
it's good for the employees and why you
should ultimately be moving in this
direction and I will defer to everybody
else's opinions on the other aspects but
I did want to let you know that the cost
is the cost
um if you do a cost benefit over the
life of the public entity it's going to
be a good investment
The Upfront cost it really depends on
what they're doing now and there's just
no way to know
so
thanks a bunch
um I just my watch just gave me a
message that said no I'm not we are on
TV so um so someone who's watching on
YouTube and informed me so
um but um uh thank you for the
information I will just point one thing
out that I noticed right off there
there's one of the the um uh links
refers to the benefits of the OSHA
on-site consultation program
um which I understand is a great program
but it does not come with this package
no it does not however I wanted to make
sure that everyone knew what a great
idea it was and why we really should do
that and I think it would answer a lot a
lot of the issues that we've had about
startup costs and what the department
can do so
um but that's for another bill obviously
when we decided to do
um oh just adopt OSHA standards rather
than create an OSHA state plan
um the consultancy program would have
come with the
OSHA state plan
um and basically we made a decision not
to go that route at this point I'm
predicting that somewhere down the line
whether it's two years five years or ten
years
someone will a white will go on in
somebody's mind and says say isn't there
Federal money that comes with a state
plan the answer is yes and they'll say
shouldn't we go after that and we'll see
what the answer is to that question but
I think this is a good start
um
I I think the the one-year uh lead-in
will relieve a lot of anxiety allow a
lot of good things to happen over the
course of that year
um and allow the department to work with
employers allow the employers to work
internally to figure out where they're
going what they need to do and I think
that that'll work out I'd like to hear
what other members of the subcommittee
given the
given the testimony and the amount of
better because it seems like there's a
large ramp up at DOL and then having to
get it out all of the town cities and
state agencies
I think representative Holcomb made a
good point that the fiscal year for
schools and uh
that time schools and towns are
yeah right it's uh July 1 so I think
putting it halfway through the year uh
would be awkward
um so I I think you know having it
Implement at the beginning of a fiscal
year
um might be better than having it uh
Implement halfway through a fiscal year
and again
uh I frankly wouldn't feel awful about
it being a 60-day uh uh implementation
because of the way our Department of
Labor Works
um people are not going to get whacked
over the head the minute uh on this
takes effect
um giving them a year to ramp up and and
um get ready uh everything sounds like a
Cameron
um
what's that yes yes
um Miss noord could you answer a
question for me
um Maine just did this a few years ago
yes
um do you know what their cost was to
the towns and municipalities
Maine is an interesting case because
they already had so much of this in
place before they actually went ahead
and got OSHA compliant
um and so basically what they ended up
doing is I believe it was Governor
LePage is that the one that was in a few
years before the current governor he
looked somebody educated him and said so
we're already doing this training we're
already doing all of the inspections
we're already doing all of these things
why the heck are we not getting the
federal funding that we're entitled to
for doing this and so they took I know
it took them a year or two because since
they had a lot of regulations they had
to sort of go back and forth and say
Here's what Maine does here's what OSHA
says how do you reconcile those
um and so there was some time in that
but ultimately it saved them money
specifically they they had adopted the
OSHA safety standards as we are
attempting to do now they had done that
but they also had a bunch of other
things in place so they sort of
cherry-picked because they have a longer
history of putting in regulations sort
of piecemeal like something would come
up so they'd put in a standard that they
would enforce and so it happened sort of
organically up to a point and then they
just sort of embraced the rest of the
OSHA standards and then at a certain
point they were like well we're like 90
of the way there let's take this last 10
percent and get the money and then what
they they did is they end up getting 50
of what they were spending so it
actually saved them what 40 percent
right so I can't put a dollar amount on
it I'm sorry I know that the Deputy
Commissioner has been to Maine he might
have a better idea that than I do
thank you
I need to go back to that 18 months
versus the year the um
the schools right now are putting
together their budgets for the 24-25
20 23 24 year
um so if we put this so that it becomes
effective on July 1st of 2023 we're
already making them have to expend money
that they didn't budget so I would think
that this should really be
July of 2024 so that it can be properly
budgeted
so these schools have pretty large
maintenance departments and some of
their maintenance departments are taken
care of
um the HVAC equipment the maintenance on
the HVAC equipment as well as ball
fields but we just had our deliberative
session in Hillsboro for the
I think you got I think you got me lost
there on the dates
amazing myself yeah you you're
originally they were talking about July
of 24. okay that's a year that's the end
of the school year okay
I thought that's what we were talking
about not not this July let me so the
budget we just put together was what
July 1st 2023 to June 30th 2024. so we
have to make this effective after June
30th 2024 so
you're correct in that
is that what you were thinking pardon I
I want to do it before this group of
people is done yeah I want this I think
it should be in place when in this
session and and I think
if there are budgetary issues that that
come up that have can't be covered now
um the department will work with uh
school districts as they have in the
past to say if you don't have the money
in your current budget to make this
adjustment we'll work with you but I'm
uncomfortable putting the entire thing
on hold for two years that's that's a
long haul
um and so I I think they'll be okay if
they can't make the appropriation until
um uh next year June of 24
um but I I think it's important to have
these standards in place before that I
think give give folks a year
to um
with with the standards and if they need
more time to make Appropriations the
department as we've heard will allow for
that
increase in taxes
I mean we're increasing taxes for our
property for our for our residents we're
increasing safety and by increasing
safety money is saved in the long run
that's the OSHA does studies on this all
the time and they find that their safety
programs
don't cost money they save money
Maybe not immediately
but they do save money
did you want this to look 25 June of 25
is that what you were thinking no I had
you were correct I had my dates off as
far as the the scheduling of which
budget was happening now versus then so
and and essentially what this bill will
be signed into law
um if we get it past everything else
um in June of 2000 um
23 23 which means it would take effect
in on June or July 1 of 2024. so it
actually does it does work it does work
but
yeah I don't disagree that that safety
I'm not against
but to say we're not increasing taxes
because we're saving money because it's
reducing incidences and everything else
that may be true in larger cities or in
different areas but it may not be true
in a lot of these small towns that don't
have a lot of claims and they don't have
a lot of incidents so how are we you
know we're increasing taxes for those
towns to to adopt to the OSHA 1910
standards well they may not have any
claims or they may have minimal claims
I just wanted to ask because the comment
was made that Maine was 90 there before
they adopted these standards can
somebody in the room answer the question
where we think our municipalities are or
departments are
um in relation to that number
nobody know we we're we're under the
Department of Labor safety standards now
um so essentially it's not that we have
no safety standards we have them some of
them are unfortunately more vague than
they should be some of them aren't
written into this the rules at all and
when challenged they fall back on the
general duties Clause so do we I mean
we have not adopted the OSHA standards
Maine did
I think what we're trying to do here is
to do the same thing Maine did so that
we can get up to the 90 percent
um and it's it's not again that we don't
have any safety standards we do
we're just trying to make it more
specific more clear more fair so that
um when
a an employer gets called on having
unsafe
conditions we're not falling back in the
general duties to say
um it's just not safe and you should
have known better you can point to the
actual standard and say Here's the
standard here's what it says
specifically and here's how to um get uh
up to Snuff so I know Mark was thank you
Mike
thank you Mr chairman uh I I did want to
put this discussion in context if I
might uh and again this is a maybe a
history lesson for some people but in
1993 Governor Greg at the time came to
laburn came to management and and
basically said the the workers
compensation system is in trouble uh we
were at a place where nobody would write
insurance in the state of New Hampshire
so he convened a group of people to get
together
and from that came reforms to the
workers compensation system and this
speaks to the cost issue for employees
for employers
and it's part of that that uh consensus
uh opinion that went forward to the
governor and that was eventually signed
there were some major changes made in
the unemployed in the workers
compensation system that affected
workers in a very big way and lowered
costs of communities number one was we
went from 66 and two-thirds when you
were injured to 60 percent major change
we went from 350 weeks of duration of
benefits to 262 weeks for duration of
benefits major change part of the deal
we we went to uh we went to managed care
we went to uh return to work policies
were put in place and part of the
trade-off for that and in those who were
around during that period of time and
keep reminding us every time we bring up
go from 60 to 66 and two-thirds they
remind us that there was this deal was
cut part of that deal the Cornerstone of
that deal for labor was that we have
comprehensive safety and health programs
within our within our workplaces we
traded off big to get these kinds of
programs so when employers say that
we're concerned about the cost
we're paying for that the employees are
funding many of the costs of those
safety and health programs with reduced
benefits major savings for employment
now I can't I can't put a number on that
but I can tell you having served in the
workers compensation appeals board
um for more than 20 years
there were many cases there were
hundreds of thousands of dollars that I
saw over the course of the years
or major savings to employers
and I think that needs to be taken into
consideration entered into the record so
what we were asking for at the time we
want a safe workplace and I was looking
at a report that come out
um
from the monthly labor review and they
also said at the time that there and I
didn't remember this but there was also
a safety incentive program in which the
uh was supposed to be a discount from
the on the insurers if there was a
safety health program in place
and that was uh and that was noted in
the in the main so what I one of the
things that I'd like to know is in fact
are these incentives being translated
into reduced costs to the employees at
the time uh so that's a major I just
want to make sure that goes on the
record and let me just say one other
thing we stopped as a Department of
Labor asking for certificates of
compliance we only required them to do
it once uh it used to be every year they
had to file a certificates that they
were in compliance uh with the law we we
did away with that so they only have to
file one slip now I did I pulled
Hillsborough County uh I went right to
Nolo I pulled their plan uh they haven't
filed anything with the Department of
Labor for years because they had they
did one time uh and I'm looking now for
the other departments which in
Hillsborough County because I don't know
where the safety plans are for the for a
number of different departments within
Hillsborough County so I don't know if
you guys I don't know if the ball was
dropped uh I don't know how much
oversight there is in these safe in
health programs now but it was an
important component for employees and we
gave up a whole lot of stuff to get to
where we are so that's what I'm I just
we need to say that we need to
understand what happened thank you Mr
chairman
I got to tell you I'm a little befuddled
today
I'm befuddled at the lack of people here
in the audience of the subcommittee
because of all the complaints about the
cost that this was going to bring
and there's no one here to talk about
the costs
there's no one here a young lady of the
municipal Association left well where
have you you have a pro you know if you
have something to say don't sit there if
you have a problem with the cost
associated with this for your members
um that seemed to be the the big little
Abalone representative Abalone and I
were talking about this you talk about
it representative colcum is this a 28a
issue what's the deal what's this going
to cost it's going to cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars for the bigger
cities
I guess no one has a problem with the
cost
well
um your choice
um this is an open forum for everyone to
speak but I've heard Zippo
a little bit about the cost associated
with this and and uh I'm just kind of
surprised I think it's a I think is a
game going on uh in in with lobbyists uh
and conquered right now
um that they really don't care what's
going to happen in the house because
they don't have any faith in it so we'll
just deal with it in the Senate uh the
the amount of people who've come and
testify in front of us is the smallest
amount I've ever seen at any years I've
been in this committee so I guess
there's not an issue here if you want to
speak you're welcome to speak but
apparently there there doesn't seem to
be any Hue and cry if there's a
financial issue associated with this
bill
thank you I provided a letter last night
that was in follow-up to my testimony
from the hearing
um relative to the cost and that was
received okay excellent
um I just want to touch on a couple of
things because one of the issues that
was asked during the hearing was whether
a reduction in workers comp claims could
sort of offset any cost that
municipalities would see in response to
this bill being filed and so what I did
was I reached out to primex which is the
prime main insurer of workers comp for
schools counties Village districts towns
cities
Etc to find out
any anecdotal information or data they
could give me about that and exactly the
same as what was stated previously by
the department of administrative
Services the primary driver or the
primary cost of workers comp claims
relates actually to slip and Falls which
usually has to do with Footwear choices
and rushing and carrying things that are
too much and that was the information
that I got from primex so they were not
able to give me information that would
show that this would decrease workers
comp claims enough to offset the initial
cost of getting up into compliance I'm
not able to give the subcommittee any
specific cost as I was not able to do
during the hearing as well but what I
understand the costs would be compliance
costs could be legal costs it could be
hiring additional staff there's been
reference to small towns who would they
designate as the safety person or the
safety officers many of them might need
to hire additional staff in order to do
that there could be legal costs there
could be costs relative to
infrastructure upgrades or Acquisitions
in order to come into compliance with
1910 and so there's just a Litany of
costs that we know would be incurred we
just can't give specific numbers on what
those would be until after coming into
compliance has occurred I appreciate the
conversation of the subcommittee talking
about delaying the effective date in
order to educate or to bring along the
public sector with respect to the 1910
standards and there's been conversation
by the subcommittee about how an
investment in safety in the Long View
can lead to decrease in costs and
obviously benefits to public sector
employees
I can't disagree with that but I would
suggest that state implementation of
State policy should come along with
State investment in that policy to make
it done right to make it effective and
to make it last and so so there's been
some conversation in this subcommittee
this morning as well or this afternoon
we've hit the afternoon
um about the idea of a fund that would
defray costs or something along those
lines and that gets closer to where we
would need to be to ensure that our
cities and towns especially the smallest
ones can come into compliance I
appreciated the testimony this morning
about how a small town like Candia would
look to the New Hampshire Municipal
Association to keep them updated on
changes in the law I can say that nhma
would be happy to be able to provide
this kind of comprehensive guidance to
our members but this is a complex expert
area and there's only so much we can do
with the general guidance we provide to
all 234 cities and towns as well as the
village districts and many of the
counties so that is really a reiteration
of the letter that I submitted I did try
to look into some of those items for the
committee and those continue to be our
concerns
thank you Mr chairman so in my
understanding
your testimony correctly that the
largest number slip and false and
as far as the large number of claims and
money so is that saying then that we
really have a small percentage of other
incidents reported to that
sorry I didn't want to cut you off
um I I don't know the answer to that I
just tried to get a sense for if these
if additional standards like the 1910
standards went into effect would that
really
um address the Lion's Share of claims
that drive workers comp costs and the
response I got to that was no as far as
more granular data about well how does
it break down then and how would
increase or expanded standards affect
the different types of claims we see I
don't have that kind of specific data to
where there isn't one I mean in maybe
doing it in smaller steps might be
easier I mean is is there a specific
the I would say the reason we're doing
this is because we want to have the
specific safety standards that are being
often you um put in place through the
general duties Clause
um as part of New Hampshire
um uh statute because
the Deputy Commissioner during our study
committee readily acknowledged that
there are substantial gaps in the um
Department of Labor safety standards and
that those safety standards have not
been updated
um
in any of the 10 years that he's been
here so we were we were due to be
um
fix our safety standards and the the
most effective way of fixing it in the
opinion of the study committee was to
adopt the OSHA standards which over time
will be reviewed that's what OSHA does
every year they review their standards
and as they get reviewed and updated
rather than New Hampshire having to do
it which we haven't
um OSHA will do it and we we have uh by
Statute adopted the OSHA standards we
will have updated standards every year
going forward
Okay so
as I as I said I think earlier in some
of our hearings you know I've
in some I I'm I'm for the safety I mean
I come from the construction industry I
understand the importance of it I
absolutely believe that we should be
making sure everybody goes home every
day in one piece
um but I'm wondering if we aren't
biting off more than we can chew in this
one bill and I'm saying that only
because I'm I'm new so with me being a
first-time rep and having not read the
entire 1133 pages that was sent to me
I'll admit to that
um you know I'm wondering if if we're
taking too big of a step on this and if
maybe we should do this in increments
I think with the study committee
concluded was that too big a step was to
take on the state plant
um in that basically let's take a
smaller bite and adopt the safety
standards let our department of labor
um
implement it and oversee it
we won't really interact with OSHA
directly we'll interact with the
Department of Labor that we're used to
and frankly as we've been discussing all
afternoon
who are
um
involved in fixing safety standards not
punishing safety violations and so
essentially we'll have the standards
we'll have a department that acts uh
reasonably with public employers but I
don't know how you pick and choose which
safety standards are more important than
other other safety standards we
presently have no electrical standards
in the department of labor standards
nothing for electricity
so well
but but to to choose that over
everything else I I don't know how to
that I can do that so
um
basically we did decide to go light and
not do the state plan
um
it's not I want to do the state plan
we're not and then I'm okay with that I
think this will work
um I'm also conscious of the fact that
we're past 2 30 and we've got another
study
um I'm not study but uh subcommittee
that's supposed to start at 230. I would
suggest though that we've not reached a
conclusion
I think we're moving towards one but I
think another meeting of this
subcommittee would be prudent so that
we
can finish her work and I suggest that
we set that time uh now so that we can
put it on the record people who have an
interest will know of it be um because
uh if it's going to be next week it
won't be in the calendar it only
requires 24-hour notice but I'd like to
give them a little bit broader notice in
that
Mr chairman if I might yes to
representative colcum
this was they were actually
three different parts of OSHA
compliance that we could have enacted
and then the biggest one which is the
full vote
which representative Sullivan and I
disagree on on going that route but the
three things picking this General
conditions was about as minimal a step
we could go to some would say we didn't
do enough
um this was a great way to take the
Department of Labor who hadn't updated
their things in 10 years
um a very uh simple step
um and one of the least we thought at
least
um obtrusive
to people that it would affect Mr
chairman if I might ask the the
individual um who who testified just now
question
what I would like to know
is if the municipal Association is
against this bill passing as is with the
time frames that we've outlined I'd like
to know
specifically why and what you would do
to make it palatable
so you don't have to have an answer
right now but in if if you're if you're
if right now you are as an organization
talking to your members and they're
saying we do not want this past and
you're going to Lobby against this to
other state representatives I'd like to
know why and if there's anything we can
do to fix that
um I think
I think policy positions that are
adopted by its membership every two
years we have like a town meeting where
we adopt our policy positions
um but we also have a 25 member board of
directors made up of local officials and
we take specific bills to our board of
directors including when bills are
amended or changed to discuss the issues
with our board and to discuss specific
positions on bills if they don't fit
neatly within our policies or if the
bill has potentially been amended to
make it better than it was for us than
when it was originally filed so I am
happy to bring this bill to my board and
it's actually already on our agenda for
tomorrow
look looking at a future meeting uh
what is our time frame Mr chairman for
uh
our time frame is
um the third week of March we have to
have our final executive session to get
rid of our remaining four pieces of
legislation from the labor committee
I don't want to wait to the last week no
but that is our drop dead deadline
um looking at next week we we've got I
wouldn't want to do it anytime before
Thursday because there's going to be all
the build up to a massive two-day
session
and which would leave only Friday
I don't know if there's a stomach for
having a subcommittee meeting on a
Friday
is anyone here in this room
participating here going to be away
that makes more sense then well I mean
some people may not be here but um
excuse me they can watch or they can
bring people here you're right I don't
want to do a marathon two days next week
plus a Friday
I would rather do it the week after and
um if I'm not mistaken representative
abalani uh uh Monday through Wednesday
are not as easy as Thursday correct
how about we do Thursday next uh the
second
yes
um
time
morning's open why don't we do 10
o'clock where is is 10 good
Lino
yeah
okay
foreign
so we had this amendment drawn up
we received information from an attorney
who went through the um the bill and she
proposed some ways to make it
better
and of course now I can't find her thing
she pointed out that when in the
original bill
that we should prevent any employment
discrimination including demotions
reduced hours reduced pay not just
termination based on a registered
patient's use of medical cannabis and
second the language should be clarified
to ensure a person who is registered as
a patient cannot be punished for either
for their status as a patient or for
testing positive
so those things are addressed in the
amendment
the third the third point that she she
was making was that where the drug
screening tests are required for the
safety of persons and property at the
job site should be eliminated because
testing for metabolites is not ever
necessary for the safety of a person on
the job site and she she went on to
state that this is not in Statute in
other states that have these types of
protection
so that would make it a unique carve out
I believe that
um
that we might even shoot ourselves in
the foot if we left that Clause the way
it is now I'm confused on that point uh
what what is not in other statutes and
which foot are we shooting
foreign
I am on the wrong part
um
could you restate the question
you said something about a piece of this
is not in the statute in other states
I'm not sure which piece you are
actually I'm not looking right at it now
testing I'm going to go ahead and read
what she said
um
testing for metabolites
is not ever necessary for the safety of
a person at a job site metabolites do
not show a person is impaired and they
stay in one system for 30 days Most
states do not have any similar exception
to the to those words in the bill where
it says wear drug screening tests are
required for the safety of persons and
property at the job site and she
suggested that should be eliminated and
so that's what the one of the things
that the amendment does is eliminate
she had a final Point as well about the
amendment and that was that there should
be explicit exception for if negative
action is required by federal law or
regulations a federal contract or
licensing requirements
and so we added that to the end where it
says this section shall not apply in
cases where this limit conflicts with
the employer's obligations under federal
to fulfill a federal contractor
licensing obligation
and then it see nothing in this section
shall be construed to require an
employer to allow being impaired by
cannabis products while at work
so basically I the way I see the
amendment is that it clarifies some of
the language that would be using in the
bill that we want to we want to avoid
um
we want to we avoid redundancy but we
also want to look at we want to look at
um
any employment discrimination not just
not being hired or being fired which is
the second the second part being that a
person who's registered cannot be
punished for their status is added in to
the bill
where it already states that for testing
positive
I don't believe there is any testing
available to tell the difference whether
would you call it a metabolize
metabolite metabolites yes uh is is
there any testing available to to
differentiate between that and whether I
smoke the joint on the way to work this
morning
and uh
that's a really good question
during the hearing
I don't believe I was able to circulate
what I would like to have but I have a I
have a photo of one of the prescription
bottles and it has all of the
ingredients
that are on in in one of the capsules
that they synthesize and it has all of
the ingredients that in it written on
the outside of the label so you might be
taste taking something that's strictly a
cannabinoid that has no THC in it which
is the psychoactive
chemical that's in in the plants that
we're using for therapeutic cannabis and
in all cannabis plants actually
no you cannot do a THC level like you
can do a blood alcohol level or like you
can do you know
detect the trace elements of of other
drugs that are of shorter duration
but the thought that what happens when
cannabis is very different in in every
person but it
routinely leaves breakdown products in
the blood in the fat of your body that
persist for a long period of time that
really have nothing to do with
impairment
so
I remember during the hearing that it
came up people were asking well how
would I know if this person was impaired
or not well do they smell like smoke do
they act impaired are their eyes glassy
are they having trouble staying on topic
um are they able to perform the duties
of their job just as if someone was
showing up impaired from alcohol or
cocaine or for anything there are
noticeable behaviors that you would want
to
address with a person if you felt that
they were intoxicated on the job
however this bill is really not about
that it's more about if I decide that
I'm going to take upon myself
that I would like to be treated in the
therapeutic cannabis program for
whatever reasons I may have maybe I'm
allergic to opiate medication maybe I'm
afraid to have surgeries and things that
are that are recommended in the
traditional medicine world and and maybe
those things are really violent and
difficult you know cause constipation
and illness and where you wind up taking
like many more medications than I'm not
questioning why you know why you're
taking it I'm just I just want to know
what can we differentiate between I took
a pill or whatever last night
okay and I smoked a joint this morning
before I came to work and I'm all messed
up uh you said you know the the the uh
you know the job performance and I don't
think that'll hold up in a court of law
you know police officers are having a
hard time
arresting people for driving under the
influence of marijuana because there's
no test
and um you know the the potential for
for widespread abuse and workplace
yes
a couple of questions on um on your
Amendment line 13 and 14 talks about the
federal contract and Licensing
obligations so I'm going to make an
assumption that that would relate to the
dot licensing standard right so if I'm
if I have a position available
that require somebody to get a DOT
license to drive a truck that they need
to be able to pass their DOT test and if
they're
if they're using cannabis they cannot
pass that test
correct and they cannot work for you
okay uh in the service industry there
are
um
oftentimes if not almost all the time we
have service vehicles that are given to
technicians
um or whatever over the road crew there
is for service
um that do not require a DOT license
however they do require them to be
driving a company vehicle a company
supplied vehicle in which the company
would then be I'm assuming under the on
the hook for any accidents that may
happen so is there a an exclusion for
service Industries where a company
vehicle or any position where a company
vehicle is provided
I have one more problem not in statute
okay and then on line 15 and 16 I'm a
little bit confused here it says nothing
in this section shall be construed to
require an employer to allow being
impaired by cannabis products while at
work why would we be requiring an
employer to be impaired
does that am I reading that wrong
nothing in this section shall be
construed to require an employer to
allow being impaired by cannabis
products while at work
there's something missing there
please
well why would we require an employee to
be impaired I mean
so I'm taking this as as I do you mind
I am looking at this where it says
nothing in this section shall be
construed to require an employer to
allow being impaired by cannabis
employees products well excuse me
cannabis products while at work there is
missing to allow employees being
impaired I'm not even sure if that's
grammatically correct but there is a
word missing there I I think the
employee is implied there
um I don't I don't think it's it's
necessarily missing if someone thought
it would be clear with it there then I
don't think it would do any harm but uh
the the word is implied
um so when it says being impaired it
implies that that means an employee
rep McKenzie thank you
um
so let me try to get this straight in my
own mind and so
what this is is a cannabis is a
alternative to other medication that's
currently out there that this is another
offering uh
two people uh to try to control pain and
other things so this is kind of am I
correct in saying this is a
um part of an offering that employees
under state law anyone who is an adult
in New Hampshire and children under
certain circumstances
um
can apply to be certified for the
therapeutic cannabis program and there
are there's a broad spectrum of
diagnoses that you could be treating
so if someone may be there someone could
be treating
um
Crohn's disease for example and if you
know anything about Crohn's disease it's
a it's a like an autoimmune disease in
some regards and it has a lot of side
effects the treatments that control
Crohn's disease have profound effects on
the body we're talking about steroids
and and all types of
try this try that try a lot of things
kind of disorders that's where the
program started we started with people
who had cancer and people who were
having difficulty
doing their jobs because of the fact
that they have something like Crohn's
disease or they are coping with cancer
and they need to just get over the
nausea and they want to continue working
so it it really has very little to do
with the relationship that they have
with their employer except that
you could get fired or you there's
nothing in statute that says that you
can't be fired on the spot and I have a
doctor who told me he said the guy I I
said I said to him I said what do you do
do you worry about people with the
Cannabis and he said actually a person
lost their job and this is so for for my
doctor to break character and talk with
me about that I knew it had to be really
important
and that's also part of why this is
before you
thank you
um
so when I when I'm trying to just
make sure I understand clearly and and
maybe help
broader understanding this is
this is a this is a
another opportunity for people to to buy
into something you get into something
that could help them
in a way that that other drugs may not
may not be effective
and what I what comes to mind for me is
that this is kind of it has this stigma
associated with it so when you mention
you know this whole list of things that
you can use to control pain the various
symptoms when you may as soon as you
mention cannabis it seems to have a very
different uh
um you know very different
reaction from people and yet this is a
treatment program that people are under
that makes them allows them to be part
of uh of they can work they can function
they can be pain control can be better
all of these kinds of things and so as I
understand what you're advocating for is
this and don't test me and throw me out
because I chose I chose this uh this
process or this this uh treatment
program compared to this treatment
program it should be there should be a
whole list of things that my doctor
would recommend or that would be
recommended to me am I characterizing
that correct
yes you are you are you this is an
opportunity for someone to try an
alternative treatment but one of those
barriers would be the kind of Reefer
Madness mentality that stops people from
even wanting to try the program
um
and it you know in another committee I
had someone say to me that they thought
that
you perhaps I'm saying that that
cannabis is benign I'm not saying that
I'm just saying that the other
medications that you take have profound
impacts on the body whereas if you go to
an alternative treatment center and you
wanted to treat your Crohn's disease you
may find that your blood pressure is
coming down and you may find that your
skin is clearing up from something that
was really out of balance and there's a
whole bunch of other things that that
tumble on in your General Health begins
to improve when you're not taking so
many Pharmaceuticals to deal with the
profound side effects that some of these
diseases require you to endure so it's
an opportunity and and we have case law
behind us that says that a disabled
person should be allowed to continue
their work in the program and that's
mentioned in in the communication that I
received I'm going to make sure that you
all get a copy of this but the Americans
with Disabilities Act
um is really what we're looking at here
as well and we do have precedent you
know behind us on that because in the
case of a pain versus right away which I
think I sent out to you in your email
um that the the Supreme Court held an
employee's use of therapeutic cannabis
recommended by their physician over
the um the you know the point was being
that this was his disability so that
that prevailed and that law
in fact I think that was an overturn
so there was a
it was a reversal of a decision
and these suggestions basically come
from that from just making sure that you
know we're talking about what is the
engagement process with a person and
their employer once they decide to enter
this program
so when I look at the way things are now
if I were employed at the hospital
that I formally worked at it would be
under under this bill should it become
law I would be able to say well I am a
therapeutic cannabis patient does that
mean you won't hire me
um and they're going to say well it
depends on what we would want you to do
what kind of tasks are involved in this
job so I you know there's there's a lot
of situations where I think you have to
trust the employer or we don't want to
tell employers what to do but we also
don't want everybody who's tried the
therapeutic cannabis program to be fired
for having the card or testing positive
for cannabis okay I don't have a problem
with
having a urinalysis or
or a serum drug screen for an employee
that needs to be working in anything
sensitive or or even just to focus on
their I I think that if there's cocaine
in there the employer should know if
there's other illegal drugs in there
that are not prescribed for anybody
opiates without a prescription which
would you know you would want the
employer would want to know that but of
all the things that people can be taking
with a prescription that they're not
being tested for
it's really it's really impactful when
you compare the two
so I'm not saying no we don't want to
test people but I'm saying if you test
for cannabis and you're in the program
we should not violate your the rights
your if you have a disability or an
inability to do your work then you
should be able to
thank you
I I am a supporter of the therapeutic
cannabis program in general
um
but I am trying to thread the needle
here
with telling businesses what to do
comment you just made so in my uh I'm an
insurance in the insurance business and
we have a lot of vehicles going up and
down the road and one of my clients has
60 some little service bands
that they're going all over the place
and they have a strict rule if you get
into a car accident
and you will automatically have to have
a drug test and if you have any kind of
drugs in your system
you will be terminated
so
I don't want to come between their rule
and what's good for the therapeutic uh
you know canvas program and the people
that need it
and I I apologize the beginning of your
testimony I had to leave the room
so we all watch these shows on TV the
the uh um Forensic Files and they can
determine
um what the blood alcohol content was at
this and the average body metabolates
metabolizes uh so much alcohol and a
soap period and they can figure out you
know how many hours has been or whatever
are there any type of studies out there
that can show us
that someone that has a THC level of
whatever
I don't even know the numbers is not
someone who is impaired
versus
at a certain level it is because if
someone has
cannabis on a Sunday
okay and they're fine and they take it
to go to sleep Sunday night and they go
to the office on Monday and something
happens or or to go to work Monday they
may still have it in their their
bloodstream
doesn't mean they were impaired
do we have any information that would
numerical or anything to use so we don't
have people getting fired
it can't just be well I'm on cannabis
I'm on the Cannabis program so you can't
fire me because I happen to have
something in your blood because you
don't know if the person wasn't paired
or not
and that's what I'm trying to figure out
is there anything we can have
the committee to show whether someone
so many parts per million or what I
don't even know what the the
there is no test that you can where you
move around it
um there is no test that I know of
that's going to tell you right on the
spot whether or not someone is impaired
with cannabis I think that it's just as
any in any other situation when you are
standing in front of somebody who's
impaired you begin to be suspicious and
wonder and you know it
um and when you're pulling somebody over
or observing something
be so the same situation someone has the
Super Bowl right starts at 6 30 at night
drinks till it's over gets up the next
day goes to work maybe has a point point
zero zero zero one left of alcohol in
their body they go out they're in
trouble because they've got in a car
accident and that tiny bit of alcohol is
going to show up and it's not going to
be an alcohol related accident even if
person was exhausted and they stayed up
all night if they don't have that 0.08
in their blood then they're not going to
be
punished that in in regards to that with
cannabis no you don't get to do that but
at the same time it's you don't well we
shot down this this um this
bank robber and
he had cannabis in his urine or in his
serum so I mean there's this thing
there's things that there encounters
that you have with the police there's
encounters that you have with your
employer and there's encounters that you
have with your family and and people in
everyday life where you wonder if
they're impaired or not and you can't
prove it so I think as an employer you
have to think about
um how it's just a different it's a
different way to look at it I I think
because you want to be people really
want that specific information about
cannabis but it's just not possible
it's not it's not possible and when you
look at
um
my ex-husband was a programmer and he
used to tell me Well an inventor and a
double e guy and everything but he used
to tell me that he said cocaine is the
drug that all the people I know used to
use and I said why is that and he said
because you can get it as blasted as you
want can we can we keep this to the bill
certainly
representative Sullivan
a couple things um one is I'm reading
facial expressions and I see folks in
four people behind I have no idea what
your expertise might be and such but it
might be if
the the prime sponsor I've been Prime
sponsored many bills that I didn't know
everything about
um and you're doing a great job but uh
I'm one I'm wondering who who else has
something to to contribute and I've got
something more to contribute a minute
too so could
if it's okay with the chair could we
find out if there's other people they're
I had a sneaking suspicion you might
know something
um
I think that that would be very helpful
um and I'd also like to make a couple
points I'm reading the bill and um
there are some things this bill says you
can't do
um to representative uh infantein's
Point
um the guy with all the little um uh
delivery Vans
cannot fire an employee just because
that employee
tested positive for cannabis
and has a
therapeutic cannabis card if the if the
if those two things are true you can't
fire them
um however
you can fire that person if that person
showed signs of impairment
so what you what the employee can't
claim is it doesn't matter if I'm
falling down it doesn't matter if my my
speech is slurred I've got a card
so I'm off scot-free so the uh the
employer can't fire somebody or
discipline somebody just because
um they tested positive and have a card
um so um I think that that's important
to uh
to keep in mind I think the piece that
was
very important to uh the committee
before we got to the subcommittee level
was lines 13 and 14. this section shall
not apply in cases where this limitation
conflicts with the employer's obligation
under federal law or regulations or to
fulfill a federal contract or licensing
obligation we were trying to figure out
if the exceptions
um served our purpose sufficiently and I
don't know where we're at on that point
um but uh
that's my view of the bill I it it works
for me certainly the what the employer
is prevented from doing and what the
employee is prevented from doing seem to
be covered adequately and clearly as
long as we insert the word employee I
guess
um but um but basically that that all
seems to work the the issue that I think
we need to figure out is whether or not
lines 13 and 14 do everything we want
them to do
thank you Mr chairman the question I had
was 126 X3 has a lot of qualifying
um things for employment is this looking
to overrule
um
those restrictions and requirements
no
thank you and follow up Mr chairman
follow up
um I too share the um
question about the the amendment however
are we now
if the employee tests afterwards for
cannabis and workman's comp and and
let's say your liability insurance tells
you that you allow this employee this
person to work impaired
we're not going to cover this accident
or we're not going to cover the injury
to one of your customers where does that
where is the protection for the employer
in that
the employee is not asking the employer
if the drug test came back that they had
cannabis in their system and the
workman's compensation comes back or
your liability insurance comes back and
says we're not covering you because you
where where is the protection for the
I'm having difficulty understanding how
to answer that question I I understand
what the question is but I don't have an
answer to that question
that will satisfy the whole question I I
just keep coming back to we're not
talking about impairment here we're
talking about you being a member of the
program
and when we're talking about the
therapeutic cannabis I want people to
think if you have a many planner that's
seven by four that this pill this is
something that we would if you were
impaired I would hope that your employer
would look into everything in your
planner and say oh my goodness he did
say he was sick and he fell down you
know to see what's going on because
we're going to look at the person's
therapeutic cannabis but we're going to
be going right past the people that are
using opiates on the job perhaps because
we're suspicious of certain behaviors on
the part of the employee
so what this bill would would do is make
less suspicion on everybody there's
rules in other words when you go to you
get employed that if you develop an
illness that you wanted to treat with
the therapeutic cannabis you find the
other treatments are radical or they're
they have consequences that you don't
want to face some of those treatments
themselves are very impairing so it
leaves you in the same position as a mom
does when her daughter is going out for
a date and the kid comes to the front
door and you're like is he okay or isn't
he okay I can't tell well he didn't look
like he was high he didn't look like he
was drunk you're going to think about
these things but you're not going to
know and you're not always going to know
so where that leaves the employer with
the insurance company is somewhere in
the point of what are you having this
person do are you having them do
something that causes them to have
obligations under the federal law it's
not just the employer that has the
the employee in the employees
thank you
for sure
one more question for for uh this
representative if I may before we bring
in the the expert please
um
we're talking a lot about it seems like
a lot of the focus in our conversation
here has to do with employees and
whether or not we can terminate them or
take disciplinary action
however
um what we seem to be not addressing is
the ability or the lack thereof to deny
employment for somebody so we all have
in the in the the job world there's a
job description that's put together and
in the job description there are
requirements that are needed to fulfill
the job
and while the ADA compliance is that you
have to make a reasonable accommodations
for those who fall into the Ada there
are still specific job description
requirements that are met that need to
be met to fulfill a job whether you need
to be able to lift 40 pounds or 70
pounds or sit at a desk use a keyboard
so on and so forth so if the job
description
um
could not be fulfilled because this
person is using cannabis and maybe is
abusing the use of the Cannabis and
maybe taking more than they should
um so are you saying that the employer
should not be able to deny that person
employment
um when they find out that this person
is not suitable for that job because of
the cannabis use or abuse of cannabis
in the case that you mentioned I would
I would
prescription requirements because they
are using cannabis or maybe
well maybe they don't know the excessive
use but they could probably tell based
off of the interview process but
if they
feel the use of cannabis is going to
impair their ability to fulfill the job
description
are you saying that they should be
required to hire them
no I'm not saying that
so then they can choose not to they can
choose to deny employment based off of
that
you when you mentioned at the beginning
you spoke about somebody who might be
using a little too much cannabis and
could be impaired maybe they don't know
how much is impairment and you would not
hire someone who you thought that would
be impaired
if you think someone's sitting before
you you should not hire them if you
think they're impaired during the
interview
I think this leads it to be very
yeah can we have the other room the
gentleman that uh
from Health and Human yes certainly and
if you would like me to distribute that
case law I can do that as well sure
thank you everybody for the record my
name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services Division of
Public Health Services
the department doesn't have a position
on this bill but I'm happy to provide as
much information as I can
um and answer and answer questions where
I where where I can
um one thing I'd like to offer up is is
um is is uh is the is the floor so
current law with regard to the
therapeutic cannabis program
um is is in very employer friendly
um there are two Provisions that you've
alluded to
um in the therapeutic cannabis law which
say
um
if you are a patient
possess
cannabis at the workplace without your
employer's written permission
it goes on to say that as a patient you
are not permitted to be under the
influence of cannabis without your
so it's it's important it's important to
know that as the floor
um and so there so there's already a
process
um and and there's another provision
that says there's nothing in the
therapeutic cannabis law which would be
construed to prevent you know
um discipline an action against that
employee for being for consuming at the
workplace or being under the influence
right so there's there's many protect
employer Protections in the therapeutic
cannabis law
um already so with that understanding we
moved to this bill and and the pro the
problem is a real problem and that is
you know and we all and we're all we're
all understanding it and that is
um your use the night before to to help
you sleep with your if your your
condition is insomnia
um in the morning you are no longer
Under the Influence however if you get
tested you will test positive THC what
this bill attempts to do I believe is to
say that just because you are tested
that you test positive for THC solely
you're testing positive THC and there's
no other
um uh other factor in play
you shouldn't be fired
and and so when we look at when we look
at the bill um or the amendment line
eight
um the the one of the key words here is
solely you know uh this disappointing
action this firing this denial can't be
solely because you have a card
or solely because you fail a drug test
it really does emphasize the
um the the impairment standard which is
not black and white as we know
um law enforcement has has issues
determining uh impairment they have
um they're asking for more funding for
drug recognition uh Dre drug recognition
experts you know for to help them with
uh with with field work to identify
someone's who's impaired where there's
not an immediate drug test on the side
of the road so I'm not I'm not saying
that this is an easy you know Bill to
fix
um however you know the the pendulum
right now is swung fully to if you test
positive for THC you can be fired
regardless of impairment
unlike every other
prescription medication that might be
prescribed to you
and this is not a prescription medicine
doctors don't prescribe this
um they certify a condition
um and that's why that's why this is
difficult but there's but all the other
uh medications that you would be
prescribed that you would be able to be
used to use at the workplace
you are allowed to use them at the
workplace unless you are impaired by
that product
and this does not change any employer's
impairment standard this simply says
that just because
you fail a THC drug test that alone
cannot because for that firing or
so with that I'll you know
with that I'll happily take some take
some more questions or try to answer
some of the other questions you already
thank you
um so I think what you're telling us is
that if someone has a prescription for
Percocet
um and that person is taking
um the medication on the schedule
provided by The Physician
um yeah
but the night before the morning of or
in the middle of the work day as long as
they are
taking it as prescribed and they are not
showing signs of impairment
they're okay and the employer cannot
fire them is that correct that's my
understanding with the with the
therapeutic program you need your
employer's written permission to bring
it on to the where to say you know I
understand I just trying to clarify the
uh the parallels between other
medications and in this very unique
substance that you can't get a
prescription for
and is unfortunately uh illegal
federally
it creates great problems
so thank you
um
the amendment is a much stronger vehicle
for this uh for this effort
um it improves and clarifies the the
original Bill immeasurably
um the uh
I do think that
the Crux you're exactly right as lines
13 and 14 where we set a floor for
um a carve out for uh for federal law on
Federal Regulations
um CDL you know is the most popular one
if you you know you cannot get a CDL
license you know with uh without a drug
test
um and this this language fully supports
you know that uh that industry uh I'm
not an expert on how far down you know
into state law that protection that
Federal Protection or limitation applies
um and I do think this you know uh but I
do think it's a it's a solid floor in
which to build this this model would be
easy
um to add more carve outs um say if law
enforcement wanted a carve out for state
and local law enforcement to say that
this law should not apply to them you
know that that would be an easy ad it
may already be covered I don't know um
but that would be easy to add
um never help you know Hospital
association association came in and ask
for a carve out that will be fine too
um my colleagues have reached out to to
law enforcement on you know on this uh
we haven't heard back from them
um on this but uh I believe that this is
a this is a this is a floor on which we
can continue working throughout the
session
um if the concept has Merit and and I
mean I think you know the concept does
have Merit
um
uh representative over here you know his
his question of what do you do you know
what what do you do when you're
company policy says You must
drug test for THC when there's an
accident and if there's a positive test
you get fired
well what happens when you get fired
what happens when you get fired when you
weren't impaired that when you when when
your your cannabis use was you know over
the weekend or the night before and you
know the accident once up with somebody
else's fault
um according to that policy you're
getting fired for choosing this
alternative therapy
um as opposed to opioids it's it's a
hard
it's a hard
not to unravel
um again happy to answer more questions
and I would I would actually I would
invite you know my colleagues behind me
to come and speak as well in case I've
missed some important points
I think you are right as far as you know
this we're in a we're in a tough spot it
cannabis works
for pain
um you know the the testing technology
stinks
let's face it it doesn't do anything for
any for whether you're you know just on
on no testing does you I mean you can I
don't know the numbers but you can you
can test for uh THC metabolites in your
system but those numbers don't mean
anything it just means that you have it
in your system exactly
um you know the the cut the cave outs we
could sit here for days uh you know uh
you know in the construction industry uh
the the trucking the nursing the you
know we could go on and on and on and on
and on uh school bus drivers uh School
Bus monitors anybody that's going to be
around kids uh you know we could go on
um
until technology catches up
um I'd have a difficult time you know
taking all of the rights away from
employers
you can take somebody in the financial
field goes in and makes a million dollar
mistake you know and uh you know they
they might have might have did their
their uh therapeutic cannabis at night
and smoked a joint before they came to
work and make a million dollar mistake
yet the test is the same uh whether they
did or didn't smoke that joint
um you know we're really in a tough spot
right now the pendulum is swung the
other way where there's no accommodation
um for responsible use of a state legal
product that is being used under the uh
under the direction of a uh of a
physician and an employer would say you
know they they don't want it to split to
swing any different uh you know we you
have the insurance things that the
workers comp the liability insurance
that I mean this is a a can of worms and
um you know with
can we work on it sure and and hopefully
the um this is my opinion hopefully that
the um the the technology the testing
technology will catch up and I know
there's a law enforcement a screaming
for it yeah and uh I mean we shouldn't
hold our breath for that you know I mean
the the point behind the point behind
this bill is that you know
people can't people can't work
and
I'll let Lido go ahead thank you Mr
chairman I know we're going on long
um under 126 X3 there are several
Provisions um in here for employment
um if the employer does not give his
um written permission or permission to
use
um cannabis product cannabis or cannabis
products during the day even though
their prescription or they're prescribed
certified is every four hours or every
six hours to take whatever it is for
anxiety or whatnot and the employer
doesn't give their consent to do that is
that denying them employee it's them
denying them employment because they're
not honoring their thing or can the
employee go to the Department Labor
saying they're not honoring my plan
um they're not allowing me to ingest
these products during work so so they're
I would answer this way to start and
that is
cannabis is not a prescription it's a
schedule one federally uh uh there
wasn't something going by that it's
being allowed to be used right now but
it is it is not it is not customary
um
doctors are not prescribing cannabis and
one of the one of the things uh
they so they that what that means is
that they are not saying take exactly
this amount on this regular schedule
there's no a prescription would be you
know the the route of administration the
frequency of the dose um Etc that is not
part of this program you know what for
what the providers do is certify you
know that a patient has a condition
under the law that makes you eligible
for the program uh and then that person
uses uh the product purchases the
product and uses the product to relieve
their symptoms there is no there is no
doctor's orders to say take this
particular product every four hours so
the the scenario that you're scribing
you know would it it's I've never heard
of of that particular case
um and I would be surprised
um I would be surprised that that that
that would
that would ever occur
um we allow prescribers or we allow
doctors to engage and you know uh for uh
make recommendations for dispensing so
they can call up the the atcs and say I
don't want my emphysema patient being
dispensed uh inhalable products and the
atcs have to uh abide by that um
prescriber uh uh instruction
um
I'm not but that all those things go
through us you know we I'm not aware of
any take two pills every day every four
hours uh it just doesn't happen
okay so they say Mr chairman they say
they're taking it for anxiety and they
have a lot of anxiety at work
by not allowing them to use that product
according to what it is being they're
being treated for would the employer now
be denying them employment because
they're not allowing them to do that
I don't know
because this this is where
the Department of Labor would come in
and say okay well you can't do that you
have to allow them to do that but 126
says you need the written permission and
the employer is denying that written
permission
Well I this this bill is not aimed to
replace uh the provisions in 126x
um the the requirement in 126x that says
if you want to if you want to use it you
need your player's written permission
right this this would this would this
would appear next to you know the the
current loss not intended to replace it
so if the if the employer says you're
not allowed to have it on at that you're
not allowed to have it in your
possession at work
that would that would Trump you know
I would not call that a denial under
this uh
law under this proposal under the
amendment under the amendment correct
same thing with you know using it while
at work again the therapeutic cannabis
law says you can't use it while working
in the workplace without the employer's
written permission so that I mean
that stands this doesn't replace that
this says what this says is that
if I test you in the morning and you and
you cut test positive for THC I can't
fire you solely for that like this is a
this is a person who comes to work
doesn't bring their you know their
cannabis product
um doesn't use it at work
but is using it at night not impaired
the next day gets the drug test test
positive and then it's fired that's what
this bill is trying to prevent it
doesn't impact the other Provisions that
say you need your employer's written
permission you know to to have it at the
hmm
I think there's a distinct distinction
that was brought up here that I think
it's important to note is that
um
uh in the in the workers comp
environment you are not necessarily uh
denied workers compensation because you
might have been under the influence
um there were cases many cases frankly
whether you were under the influence or
not you were injured I.E the Box falls
on your head comes off of a comes off of
a a thing and drops on your head well
that doesn't mean that if you were sober
or you were under the influence that
that accident uh that made any
difference in terms of the accident so I
think there is that distinction and that
is that is the uh work through when you
do workers comp appeals and that's how
those that those are adjudicated uh and
we think so it's not all black and white
when it comes to the issue of workers
compensation and I think
um I mean I think what I'm gaining from
this is that there is an opportunity to
offer to people uh an alternative
treatment that may be very effective
that may put them back in a very
productive environment that the employer
still has the jurisdiction over who can
use it when they can use it that the DLT
laws still exists you can't you can't
deny you know you can't drive a truck if
you're under the influence of anything
so to me all all of that all of that
exists and I think what we're trying to
carve out is that place where we bring
it in let people who have benefited from
this use it and I can bet dollars for
donuts there are a whole bunch of people
that are on opiates in workplaces they
never get tested for them
um that are taking them and the employee
probably doesn't know one one lick about
what's going on so I I think it's uh you
know I'm
you know I think we had to work on it
but I I you know I think I understand
what you're trying to accomplish it
thank you
representative Sullivan
um
I guess going back to representative
avaloni's uh question about can an
employer
um uh deny employment to somebody if
they want to use during the day I think
clearly that is
um uh they
bottom line is the employer is given
rights under
126x that says that they can choose not
to allow use during the day they can
choose not to allow cannabis on in the
workplace
um so if they exercise those rights they
can't be held a task because of that
that's number one
um number two on a somewhat different
subject I'm still sort of
struggling with lines 13 and 14. I don't
know if there's somebody here who
understands those thoroughly or not I I
don't believe you do
um and which is fine I don't
um but basically I think the the
subcommittee could benefit from a full
list of all the employer
the types of employment that are
under the language in in those lines
um I thought I heard during the uh the
Committee hearing that perhaps law
enforcement was included in that I'm not
sure if they are or not
um but basically
um
I think there's uh we would benefit from
knowing all of whom you would be
included in in that list we know that
truck drivers are
um
who else fire police EMS hospital
employees as you pointed out who who all
is included in that and I think then
once we've seen that we as a
subcommittee can discuss whether or not
anyone else needs to be added but right
now there's an invisible list at least
invisible to us
um that I think we need
I don't know is there somebody that can
provide that
no I I can I can reference the the
document that was uh referred to during
the hearing testimony was called the uh
the federal Omnibus Transportation
employee testing Act of 1991. we can
provide a copy of that that did have a
list of
um of of professions that were included
and also I if memory serves it has a
list of
um professions that
could be included
um but were not required under that so
there there's a there is there is a list
that I've seen I don't have it printed
out that is something that I can I can
Provo you know we can provide and there
may there may be some smarter people
behind me you know that have uh poor
information on on what that Federalist
is
um the the what what I like about the
amendment is that it goes beyond that
list and it talks about you know Federal
contracts so um and and federal uh
you know licensing as as well I'm still
reading body language and I think I saw
I had shakes on that uh on the on the
issue of the list okay I'm happy to I'm
happy to defer to my colleagues if they
have if they have something to
contribute Mr chairman I think would be
great
uh representative Academy
okay
uh you're talking about Federal
contracts you're talking about CMS
requirements for hospitals and whatnot
thank you yes
okay thank you for your testimony
there are other uh other experiences as
it relates to Federal contracts I mean I
you know you can't get in the shipyard
if you're under the influence of
anything but yeah everybody's tested
before the ASC Port power plant uh all
the Building Trades are tested in many
installations around that you just can't
get in them until you tested so I think
that's what that may speak to uh and and
that we're reference of federal
contracts
thank you very much for the record Matt
Simon I work for Prime ATC
one of the alternative treatment centers
in New Hampshire
I am not an expert on labor law I
probably qualify as an expert on
cannabis and cannabis policy so I can
help with some of the questions you're
answering and some maybe not so much
I think I'll start with lines 13 and 14
even though I'm not an expert in labor
law my sense is that all of these
policies are in flux at the federal
level and uh it's hard to know how they
might change in the future so I think
the goal of this sentence is to make
sure that whatever Federal requirements
may exist we know about commercial
driver's license that's one that's
certain there may be others and if they
exist then this would broadly make it
clear that employers are not required
to violate Federal mandates to
accommodate this section so
I wanted to comment on testing generally
I think first I want to explain why I
think there's a sense of urgency to pass
this bill sooner and later sooner than
later so first of all you've been given
the Supreme Court case where a court has
already ruled in favor of a defendant
and found that he was entitled to not be
fired from his job
based on
you have those details I haven't read
them in a while so I'll leave them for
you
and so we've created a situation where
that's existing case law and any patient
who
gets fired say would be able to go to
court get an attorney pay a bunch of
money go through a process and achieve
the same result that Mr Payne achieved
that's very expensive it's not a policy
change it's just we know that courts are
now viewing this and there's precedent
that the court would likely find in an
employee's favor if they're terminated
solely for either of A or B having a
active registration with the program or
so the other aspect of this as
representative McKenzie has suggested is
we hear from patients all the time
who have been prescribed opioids or
other medications that they find
impairing or debilitating in various
ways and they want to qualify for
therapeutic cannabis but their employer
has a policy that broadly prohibits them
being able to work there
on and
or they want to get a job in a field and
they fear drug testing and being
disqualified solely on the basis of them
being a card holding patient
so
we already have the case law
but until we have a change in the
statute we're not going to have clear
guidance for employers that this is in
fact how courts are considering this
issue so that's why I think there's a
sense of urgency to try to get it done
and get it into statutes so there is
that Clarity for both patients and
employers that that this is how the law
is being not only written but understood
and not to be a deterrent to patients
who want to participate in the
therapeutic cannabis program as an
alternative to opioids or other
medication
so I think the key word as Mr Holt
suggested is on line eight the word
solely and I think that's the line that
threads the needle so all of the
scenarios that I've heard presented are
what if an employee is impaired and does
this what if an employee is in an
accident while at work and and there's
always some other component Beyond A and
B
a is just they are a qualifying patient
and B is just they tested positive if a
person's driving a car a company car
while at work and gets into an accident
and they're thought to be impaired
that's more than a and b that's they did
something so I think solely is the key
word that threads the needle
and Strikes that balance
as Mr Holt suggested we've done some
Outreach trying to find out what
categories might not fit in 13 lines 13
and 14 if there is a specific carve out
needed for law enforcement if there is
one needed for any other sector and if
anybody comes forward and says we need a
specific carve out for our sector I
think the sponsor and the supporters of
this bill or more than open to including
those specific carve outs if they come
forward
but nearly every
objection I've heard has been what about
if federal law or federal contracts say
we can't so I think lines 13 and 14
address all of all of that
and I was going to comment on on
the technology that is available for
testing but if you have a question
representative I'd be happy to pause and
thank you I appreciate it there's we
keep falling back into the
um opioids and people who are in opioids
to me there's a clear difference there
when I'm prescribed an opioid opioid
it says right on my prescription do not
operate heavy equipment do not drink
alcohol do not do this do not do that
right so my my prescription itself is
giving me my limitations and it's
holding me responsible by way of
accepting that prescription and taking
it it's holding me responsible for my
actions so anything that happens beyond
that now is solely on me
from what I'm hearing
this is not the case with cannabis right
is there there is not a prescription
that says that in in if I'm wrong
because I'm seeing a head nod behind you
that I would love to be corrected on
that but is there a prescription that
says while you are utilizing this
product you should be not you should not
be operating heavy equipment you should
not be using alcohol you should same
thing is there personal responsibility
by way of accepting that prescription
thank you for the question is there
personal responsibility absolutely yes
in the therapeutic cannabis program it's
not a prescription because it can't be
doctors can't prescribe a schedule on
controlled substance so the
certification is a parallel process that
resembles a prescription but is
different in some key respects so every
product that we dispense comes with
warning labels every patient that we
take into the program there's required
intake paperwork that explains cannabis
and some of the potential risks the
patients have to sign that they've
received that paperwork
we offer initial consultations for any
first-time patient we encourage them to
sit down with one of our patient
Educators talk through the risks and
potential benefits talk to patients
about how they can get the most positive
use out of cannabis without negative
side effects without
you know most patients are not looking
to be impaired they're not looking to be
intoxicated they're trying to feel
better
and in most cases they've been
prescribed treatments that they
found either didn't work or did produce
negative side effects and particularly
with opioids impairment is one of those
negative side effects so
you know we have and some of those
patients that we've helped get off
opioids over the years some of them work
for us now and are opioid free and our
participants in the therapeutic canvas
program
and they're functioning productive
employees at our ATC
we also serve lots of patients who were
not able to work five or ten years ago
but are able to work now that they've
achieved Better Health in part through
therapeutic cannabis
so we want to get rid of that deterrent
that
it's heartbreaking to hear from patients
who say I want to be on this program so
badly
and maybe they've tried cannabis once or
twice and found that it helped them but
they have to factor in the sphere of
losing their job or not getting their
next job if they do go on the program
but to me this brings us back to the
question of being able to test this and
um to be able to test it and we keep
using the example of I used last night
and I come to work today that you know
I'm not impaired but if I used five
minutes before I walked through this
door
nobody's able to tell me that I or be
able to tell if I took cannabis before I
walked through the door of the state
house because the test is going to be
the same and you know there are many
people with very addictive personalities
I'm I've got you know one myself where
I've got an addiction to Chocolate I
can't give it up but um so they're
they're just addicted they're addicted
to that feeling I mean I've got a
brother-in-law who is in rehab so same
thing how do you control that when
they've got this addiction to cannabis
so I think that's a good invitation for
me to talk about the technology that is
available with testing so there's two
main ways that cannabis can be tested
for one is a urine test and that does
not tell you anything other than that
there are cannabis metabolites present
so an individual could test positive for
you know up to a month or even more in
some cases after most recent use
so that isn't helpful at all but
unfortunately that is how most
pre-employment drug screening is handled
and you know I have a friend who tested
he quit smoking cannabis for
I think six weeks because he wanted to
get this job
and yet he still tested positive and
didn't get the job so like it's really
uh
urine testing is not helpful in any way
except to find that somebody has used
cannabis at some point in the past blood
testing is also available and blood
testing will tell you recent use and
we'll tell you because it'll you know
cannabis will clear from your your
bloodstream
within a couple of days there will still
be traces and metabolites but actual THC
so
blood testing will tell you that
somebody's used cannabis somewhat
recently the problems now with the
technology the problem is that cannabis
isn't like alcohol and our bodies don't
metabolize it in a predictable way so
with alcohol we have a 0.08 standard
that's fairly well accepted and we know
that individuals no matter how much they
drink no matter how long they've been
drinking
you know some
tolerance might explain some people
being able to handle alcohol somewhat
better than others but we know that
anybody is impaired at 0.08 or above
with cannabis
and with cocaine and with opioids and
with just about any other substance you
could become impaired on there's no
bright line where Above This
anybody's going to be impaired and below
it nobody's going to be impaired we just
don't have that so a patient who's
taking a high dose edible every night
for pain and insomnia
is never going to be impaired during the
day you could apply a field sobriety
test you could apply an advanced Drug
recognition expert test it's a 12 point
test
designed to look for drug impairment
patient may test higher than 0.5
nanograms per liter which is a standard
in some states it's not based on
anything
but there's no evidence that they're
actually impaired so again if there's a
credible allegation that an employee is
impaired while at work
that's not covered by this bill there's
no protection by this bill
all this bill says is that these actions
can't be based solely
on status as a card holding patient or
solely on a positive drug test if you
cause an accident at work and and you
know somebody gets hurt or something
like that
and there's evidence that you're
impaired
you don't need
a bulletproof test to prove impairment
an interview process is enough to be
able to determine that so I just don't
think
I don't like the part about denying
employment I think an employer should be
able to decide that but
I I get the part about employment you
have a you can see a pattern of a person
you can you can you know a person you
when they're employed you can you can
learn their patterns you can see their
if I may volunteer one more clarifying
piece of information for your
representative the um it under the theme
under the category of setting the floor
the therapeutic cannabis program
um law 126x
um uh colon 3 it
you are not allowed to be under the
influence of cannabis while
operating a motor operating a motor
vehicle commercial vehicle boat vessel
or any other vehicle propelled or drawn
by power other than muscular power in
addition
you're not allowed to operate heavy
machinery or handle a dangerous
instrumentality so again these are other
areas where the you know just because
you're a patient using it you know you
are not permitted under current state
law from being under the influence of
the product
um and so there's there's already these
Protections in here so when we want to
answer your question about you know your
opioid prescription says don't operate
heavy machinery yeah the therapeutic
cannabis law already prevents you
um and and in in more than it more than
prevents you
you are subject to arrest even if you
have a card
and you're using it you're subject to
arrest
um if you're not compliant with those uh
those laws so I just wanted to offer
that as well as part of the floor I I
understand that it just from a
probably more committed conversation in
you as well but
from a hiring practice
if I am hiring somebody to come in and
operate a forklift in a shop and have to
be you know be able to operate this work
with I'm not going to be able to know
he's going to come in clean for his
interview this person he she whichever
um you know they're not gonna I'm
assuming they're not going to come into
the interview process impaired and
they're going to tell me all of the
right things no I don't do this no I
don't do that no I don't do this so now
I send them off to a drug screening and
find out that you know they're on they
have cannabis in their system and I have
to make a decision when I have a couple
of people here to choose from I'm not
hiring this guy he might be a little bit
more qualified but he's taking cannabis
and this guy he's also qualified but
he's not
so am I going to be able to make that
decision to say I'm not hiring this guy
of course I'm not going to tell him I'm
not hiring him because of the Cannabis
right so now he's got to prove that I
denied him employment because he's on
cannabis and the other guy's not so how
does that work I think employers deal
with those kinds of questions uh every
day outside of this realm of cannabis of
determining you know everything else
being equal
I'm going to choose this person based on
subjective uh criteria and I don't think
I don't think this I don't know this is
any different I would suggest that any
hiring process is a crap shoot
which makes this
this here says no employment shall deny
you can deny based on any other reason
Allowed by law now they're facing a
lawsuit that I you know wasn't hired
I would offer that there's 14 000
patients in the therapeutic cannabis
program just to
give you a sense of of the scope and the
the vast majority of them are outside of
working age
um and and and don't work
um many of them are working because they
now can
yeah just it's a relatively small
program this is a small population we're
talking about
representative evelini thank you Mr
chairman this has been my last question
um uh so a an employee long-term
employee gets into a car accident on
their own time
gets into this program
the employer has a no tolerance policy
uh basically you're solely becomes now
they now they're a Cod carrying member
of the program
is that superseding employer policy the
employer now cannot terminate that
employee because they have a zero
tolerance policy
I'm sorry I don't follow the I didn't
follow the the example or the anecdote
so if the employer has a zero tolerance
policy for drugs
the employee through no fault of the
employer goes out and gets into a car
accident on a Saturday night taking
their family out to dinner
they get into this program down the road
because they were given prescribed
opioids or whatever
now comes back to the
employer and says I'm now part of this
program you can't fire me
and they they got the card after the
accident after the accident still
employed by the employer
I I'm not I you know I'm not an employer
and I don't I'm not an attorney who
deals with labor law so you know I'm
unprepared to answer these these
questions as an employer that's the
question I would have
how would your attorneys answer that
question
no
I didn't know if there was something you
guys knew that we didn't on that topic
what happens during mid-employment if
this if their situation changes from a
non-cannabis using person to a cannabis
using person
under this program and the employer has
a Serial I don't know I mean we we deal
with patients who are in mid
um you know are in the midst of a uh
we we have patients who get cards after
they get arrested for possession when
they don't have a card and so part of
their plea deals become
um if you go get a if you can get if you
get your doctor to sign off and you get
a therapeutic cannabis card you know we
will you know we'll drop the charges or
you know it's the basis of a plea deal
or whatnot so that's the only experience
that I have in terms of a mid-process
process uh you know for uh getting a
card in the middle of an incident that
is under question but employment I don't
representative infantine thank you I
just I I think I follow the pattern here
but I just want to make sure I
understand it because um here a lot of
your testimonies have been very helpful
so you have approximately 14 000 people
in the therapeutic cannabis program can
you give me a ballpark about how many
are working maybe a thousand you said it
was a small amount
I don't I don't have that I don't have
that data I'm just saying that there's
many many you know 70 and 80 year olds
on the program uh as well okay so the
the log so I can read it that you're out
um that you were reciting about the as
you call it the ground floor
what is the RSA RSA 126 Dash X
okay so it's just including here this x
colon three okay okay as the prohibition
Okay so
an employer
sorry I don't want to sneeze here I just
went touching my nose um my an employer
has to
agree
as you said before they have to agree in
writing to this
correct if someone is going to be in
their employee
that is a terrible cannabis user
written permission to possess at work
okay written permission to be under the
okay I'm just trying to understand
because I've never had this happen an
employer I'm trying to understand follow
the bouncing ball to start so if someone
it comes in as a brand new employee and
wants to start and wants to be
interviewed so they're interviewed
and they inform their employer that
they're on therapeutic cannabis and they
inform them of the law that you know if
you get hired I have to have you
in writing agree that I can possess and
then be under the influence is that the
word I want to use the right word here
uh not influence but it
it's not a con it's not a condition of
employment it is a condition of those
two uh those two behaviors the behavior
is uh being in possession at work or
being under the influence at work if
you're going to do one of those things
you need your employer's written
permission you don't need your
employer's written permission to be on
the program and be under the influence
and use this product at home right you
need the the permission to bring it into
work and to use it at work so I show up
I am on utilizing therapeutic cannabis I
show up for an interview
I go to the interview or he's going fine
it's an accounting procedure I pass all
the the criteria or whatever I inform my
this prospective employer
that I'm on the therapeutic cannabis and
I explained to them what the rules are
going to be what the current rules are
in 126x
and they say oh
well
I don't want to hire you that
that's what you want to make against the
law
number one correct it says right here
you want to make yes Simply Having a
card right and
and having hair and disclosing that
information is not a fireable or
non-hirable offense yes okay
um and you want the same thing if
someone cannot be terminated or any
disciplinary work action held
um who possesses uh these things but it
says it says
current event okay but the the thing
comes down to I think is everyone
um
it comes down to B I think that's where
everyone's having the problem
individual has a positive drug test
indicating cannabis code does anyone
I do
okay is that the termination part or the
the they can't deny employees as we've
been talking about the permission slip
uh what happens if the employer says no
I'm not going to give that to you I
can't use you now he's in violation of
this okay that continues on though
um that is it also in 126 something or
whatever about they cannot use heavy
machinery cannot use a motorized vehicle
or whatever is that also in 126 further
down the yes same section okay
you guys have to read the whole law
just that one section well I mean the
whole 126 or whatever to understand it
colon 3 is it sets these these
requirements okay and from because
we're thinking globally and I get it
and I shame on me I mean I haven't read
all of 126.
to see what
well he he rattled off quite a few but I
can think of dozens more and uh if I
went home and thought about it real hard
I could probably think a 30 or 40 more
uh you know
um job titles and uh you know things
like that
um the like I said this is a can of
worms whether it's you know you're
looking at the insurance end of it uh he
mentioned you know it's it's
heartbreaking to see somebody gets by it
well it'd be heartbreaking for somebody
to lose their business because an
insurance company wouldn't wouldn't uh
wouldn't cover an accident and he ends
up losing his house and all the rest I
mean you know we could heartbreaking
things all over the place here and uh
you know nobody wants to look at the
employers the employer and what he has
representative Susie
thank you Mr chairman
I'm going to look at it from a different
perspective
um
I agree with a lot of stuff that's being
said here however I also just want to
make a statement that
I don't believe that
everybody that's on the Cannabis or the
therapeutic cannabis program
is stoned every day they go to work
I think these people
will
use cannabis at night I know several
people that use cannabis at night
and it's to relieve pain again
because you have it in your system does
not mean you're impaired so I think we
need to get away from the whole thing
that just because people are using
therapy therapeutic cannabis is that
they're in um
they're high every day because that's
not the case I think a lot of these
people are using it again for sleeping
purposes for pain purposes rather than
going to opioids
um so I think we just need to remember
that I think that's important to
remember that a lot of these people
aren't going to work hi
um and it may be in their system but
again if I take a five milligram gummy
at night at 10 o'clock when I go to bed
it's no different than me drinking four
ounces of alcohol in a truly when I wake
up in the next the next morning I'm not
intoxicated
and I'm I'm not under the influence so I
think we just need to remember that I
think you know we're running around in
circles here and it is it's it's a big
you know this is an important bill
um but I just think we need to look at
it from all perspectives thank you
and to add to that there's no there's no
way of telling who isn't either you know
um you know I won't I don't know if it's
50 50 40 60 what
who knows but you're not going to tell
me that there aren't people abusing it
too
representative infantine thank you um if
I might I'm not asking you gentleman to
leave or anything um Jody you had told
me
uh I apologize I had to leave the room
for a phone call is there an amendment
coming
okay
I thought there was an amendment that
was going to come
that was yeah from the police that was
going is that part of this Federal
um
this is this is where I'm getting at we
have a a bill that a perennial bill here
about uh credit checks for employment
okay and every once in a while it comes
through and we end up saying well it
can't be for the new it has to exclude
you know certain things the nuclear
power plant workers at Seabrook it has
to include anyone that is involved with
um
foreign is there going to be a problem
if if we end up having four or five
organizations that say we don't want to
be included in this the police Chiefs
Association doesn't want to involve this
nuclear regulatory people I guess maybe
that is covered under this federal law
number two
um but you know what happens if uh
um
other than the state police I can't
but again
okay thank you Mr chairman I've got it
uh I've got a meeting that started 15
minutes ago
um I'd love to get to but uh it seems
like we're missing two things we would
be great to hear from exactly where the
chiefs of police are coming from and
apparently we can't hear that now
um and also I would like to get the full
list of what's included in lines 13 and
14 all of those
types of employment so we we can know
where we stand there so I would suggest
we need another meeting and I would
further suggest that since the OSHA sub
um committee is going to be meeting on
March was it second March 2nd at 10 A.M
everybody else Mr McKenzie does that
work for you
the only thing I would say is that he
had very little time to talk
in the scheme of things that's the only
week we have
I could probably going to try to stay
away from scheduling anything
because we're going to get handed pretty
good next week
here
so I mean I'm trying to cop that out and
hold on to that few Nations let's retain
it themselves
but I'll try to make it existing a
message
I know that representative Susie will be
here for the other uh committee meeting
so if uh representative McKenzie you
can't I would suggest that perhaps
representative soucy could stand in in
your place
representative Bellini
thank you Mr chairman um who prepared
the handout that we were just given
uh this is a this is a document that the
therapeutic canops program has posted on
our on our website um as an
informational
um document for uh for patients um and
caregivers
um and what this there's there's no
interpretation in this document it is
simply
um collecting the bits of law in 126x
including and especially uh Roman
section three that established these
limitations
um uh and your protections as a patient
uh and so in my opinion it is clear to
go to the law X3 and read that then read
this document what this does is puts
your uh patient protections and patient
prohibitions limitations in in what in
one place
there's a therapeutic cannabis program
document that we make available
thank you um I had something revised
since 11 15. the law has not changed in
disregard since it was passed
okay because there have been no there
have been no improvements there have
been no additional protections and there
have been no additional prohibitions
since the law uh since the law passed in
2013 this document the program was
it's pretty brilliant kind of popular
it's it's making reference to
um
other laws that were changed Through The
Years 2016
um
was 247 colon 5 and 6 uh 2021 at 16 and
21 you have 9 21 122 colon 19 as well
with those with those any substantial
changes I don't I'm not seeing what's on
the back of the
it's on the part of 126 colon 3 for the
sources
I just want to make sure we're getting
I'm not seeing where you're referring to
um under the section 126 where it says
sources
if you're actually I don't know what we
just I I perhaps we were handed out to
different things I'm looking at a
document called therapeutic cannabis
program the protections and prohibitions
for qualifying occasions right I'm
looking at 126 colon 3x X colon 3.
right yep it's just it was updates and I
just want to make sure that we're here
we're still had the same I will I will
review this document again to make sure
that this is the right one but uh
changes to to those sections of the law
I do not believe impact this document
thank you just
I
just want to say one last thing thank
you for your thoughtful questions and
your interest in this topic
um like I said the department doesn't
take a position but it is an important
issue for offer patients and I
appreciate the care with which you're uh
uh taking this uh this issue considering